it is simply impossible to achieve
long-term health and happiness if you
hate yourself 100% this is so important
because this is that was I have a memory
of a point in my life where that changed
just like boom just like Tom ready
turned to switch because I I was on the
edge of I could have been diagnosed as
manic depressive why happy most of the
time but once it started going wrong
then it was like this is wrong and then
I give myself the abuse verbally oh not
you're stupid you're not good enough
what what's wrong with you lipon and I'd
be doing that and I I was in my lab and
I I just spent a procedure that took
about an hour to prepare for the
experiment and and if you mess it up
just a little bit you have to start all
over again the third time that day I
messed it all up and now I'm really
upset I spent the whole damn day doing
this it didn't work and then I'm getting
oh you idiot you can't do anything right
and I was giving myself like a parent on
my shoulder telling me where you're
that's not good enough and I'll never
forget there I was alone in the lab and
I hear this voice don't you have
anything better to do than to listen to
this crap and I looked around I started
to laugh because I said sure I'd rather
go to a movie do you want to continue
this conversation or you want to do
something else that was the moment of
empowerment that was so great because it
said stop next time I started to get a
little depressed first thing that came
back was the humor of that and I'd laugh
and I go okay I'll do something else
after three or four times guess what
I've never been depressed since that
time sit there and play it over and over
and over again which makes you go
downhill downhill I just I have a choice
do I want to listen to this stuff or do
I want to do something else hey it's
Carl Michael and I make these videos
because I need them for me because I
want to wake up every day and watch a
video that puts me in a mindset to
believe in myself more and go off and
accomplish amazing things and attack the
day and I hope that this video does that
for you as well so today let's get some
incredible motivation from the one and
only Bruce Lipton
enjoy everyone thinks diseases related
to genes and I'll tell you what less
than
1% of disease is connected to genes that
up to 90% of illness is stress related
and I go well what's the consequence
I'll tie it into the corporate thing in
a second because the first two uh
consequences of putting stress hormones
in your body are let's go back a few
hundred thousand years when the only
stress was the saber-tooth tiger chasing
you so stress is based on your ability
to escape uh and your ability to escape
is to use your arms and legs and I said
well yeah well you want all the energy
in your arms and legs because you know
uh you don't have to worry about the
gallbladder right now that's not
relevant to saber-tooth tiger coming so
there are three things that I want to
bring up so very number one the first
the first two are physical okay number
one is stress hormones cause the blood
vessels in the gut this area to shut
down in fact when you first feel fear
there's like a butterflies in the
stomach queasy feeling that's actually
the blood vessel squeezing shut and I
say why should the blood vessels squeeze
shut it's like you don't need to
maintain the body if you're trying to
escape the tiger so by squeezing the
blood vessel shut you send the blood to
the arms and legs more more energy uh
and most important part especially in
today's world is that stress hormones
shut down the immune system that's a
function it's so effective that when a
doctor wants to transplant an organ into
a foreign person and they don't want the
recipient's immune system to reject it
they give the patient stress hormones
before the transplant because stress
hormones shut down the immune system
reason is simple if you ever been sick
sometimes you don't even have the energy
to get out of bed and I go well you know
if you have a bacterial infection and a
saber-tooth tiger chasing you you know
it's like well who cares about the damn
bacteria because if the tiger catches
you the bacteria is not really a problem
anymore uh and so the uh immune system
is shut down which opens us up to a
problem and in today's stressed out
world the uh the amount of illness on
this planet with all the money we put
into Healthcare is rising all of the
time and I go it's because of the
stresses that we're we're dealing with
that's causing this your life 95% is
coming from the
program your life is a print out of your
programs you just look at your life and
recognize simple fact the things that
you like that come into your life they
come in because you have a program to
acknowledge those things
but the things you wish desire want in
your life and you work hard to make them
happen you struggle you sweat over it
I'm putting a lot of effort in I'm G to
make this happen why are you working so
hard and the answer is whatever that
destination is your program doesn't
support it and you're trying to use your
conscious creative mind to override the
program I said yeah my conscious mind is
5% program is 95% I go it's not GNA work
very well at all so that's why poor
people stay poor and rich people stay
Rich yep that's why the book Rich Dad
Poor Dad that was exactly what the whole
point was if you grow up with the
programming of a rich family you don't
have to think programming is
subconscious your thinking might be
quite stupid I mean a former president
of ours was a relatively rich person but
not very smart in his conscious mind but
his program was how do I got how I got
rich by what he downloaded that from his
family okay uh and if you're in a poor
family what did you download oh Life's a
struggle it's not I can't get there as
you know you can change it I say yeah
how can you change it remember I said
well there are two minds conscious is
creative wishes and desires subconscious
hard drive with a program I said the
conscious mind being creative can learn
from anything read a self-help book oh
yeah I know how to do that I said you
read the book I give you a quiz you get
a hundred and you says yeah you know
this stuff and then I say well now that
you know this stuff did your life change
and the answer is no I go why the
conscious mind learned from reading the
book that's not how the subconscious
mind learned so are smarts stay up here
I read the book I knew the information I
understood how it worked blah blah blah
blah blah I go yeah that's the thinking
mind that knows but I go does that
translate into subconscious I go no it
doesn't because that's not how the
subconscious mind learns you want to
change the subconscious then you have to
put in the data the way the subconscious
mind learns conscious mind creative can
learn from anything you could just go
aha I just changed my mind I can do that
okay subconscious mind habit point of
habit it resists change if a habit
changes then by definition it's not a
habit anymore so habits resist change
and yet we have these habits and we want
to change them I say how can you do it
and I say the only way you can change
the habits is the way that the habits
were learned in the first place I go
what was that I said first seven years
your brain was at a lower vibration than
Consciousness it was called Theta Theta
is hypnosis and I go oh so what do I do
I say well you you can't just say Okay I
want to go into hypnosis hypnosis is
part of a scale of low vibration going
to high during the day and then when you
come home from work the high vibration
slows down and goes to sleep at the
lowest vibration so you go through a
range of different vibrations as you're
sleeping Awakening calm conscious Focus
conscious you're at work Focus conscious
and I go then what you come home you
calm down now it's calm conscious and
then I say what then you fall asleep I
say the instant you fall asleep the next
vibration down is Theta I go that's
hypnosis I go yeah so I say then every
night the moment you fall asleep the
brain for a short period of time is in
hypnosis Theta so I say so what well you
put on earphones or earplugs and you go
to bed playing a program that you want
to be true in your life I say so what I
say you put it on just before you fall
asleep and while you're still awake you
probably hear some of the program okay
but the moment you fall asleep conscious
mind's disconnected doesn't hear
anything coming off of the program
anymore I say but what does I say ah the
subconscious mind is in Theta record so
whatever is coming through the earphones
is not going into conscious mind but
it's now being directly downloaded into
the subconscious so this is called self
hypnosis you have to repeat this process
because the amount of time in Theta is
relatively short be before you hit the
lowest vibration Delta which is sleep
outright okay so every night when you go
to bed just after your Consciousness
falls asleep there's a period of record
opportunity and then you put the
earphones on play the program it's
called self- hypnosis that's hypnosis
you're doing it yourself okay number two
you still learn programs after age seven
you learned how to drive a car you
learned how to play an instrument I go
well how'd you do it that way they go
repetition habituation is practicing
something and repeating it and repeating
it so many times that the subconscious
finally says okay I got a pattern I got
the pattern and that pattern then
becomes the Habit negative thinking is
equally powerful but works in the
opposite direction meaning with positive
thinking you could heal yourself of any
disease with negative thinking you can
die and create any disease you can
create your own death just because you
believe you're going to die and all of a
sudden I say well then it's the power of
belief positive or negative that is
shaping the world and I go well this is
why when we look at people's beliefs and
and they they do you know an assessment
of they find out over 60% of the beliefs
that we're manifesting every day are
negative and disempowering
self-sabotaging thoughts that we've
acquired such as I'm a victim of my
genes that's a belief and somebody says
yeah well I'm going to die cancer
because it's running in my C in my
family and they get cancer and then they
find out there's no Gene that causes
cancer oh or I'm I'm saying this on uh
on LY show I will have to emphasize that
there is not one gene that if you have
this Gene you have cancer genes are
correlated with cancer genes are not
causing cancer this is why half the
women that have the breast cancer Gene
brca2 half the women never get the can
answer but they all possess a gene so
where's the point they said the gene
didn't cause it it was a lifestyle that
was not in harmony that ultimately
activated what is called a cancer Gene I
said so what do you mean so if you
change your thoughts you can get rid of
cancer I go yeah well that's what
spontaneous remission is all
about and so um I'm stepping on
Lindfield here because this is where
this emanation of thought and we don't
see it and we don't in our history
oh that's just thoughts and feelings I
go those are the controls that are
manifesting your life your thoughts and
your feelings your feelings are the
translation of the energy into sensation
so your feelings are like a compass
they're telling you whether you're going
toward more life or to less life hi I'm
Bruce Lon author of the bestselling
books the biology belief spontaneous
Evolution and the honeymoon effect I'm
here to thank Evan carmichel for
featuring me on his YouTube channel and
I want to let you know that Evan is
giving away links where you can watch
the First episodes of my special Gaia
series entitled inner Revolution for
free Evan is making this offer to thank
you for watching this video you will
find the links in the description
section below thank you the most
important aspect about sleep is that it
gives a chance for the body to
recalibrate its system so when
Consciousness is out then uh the body
starts to balance everything that's
going on you know with each system the
body's pH the temperature regulation
very interesting point that when people
are comos uh they in a hospital and they
got all the wires on them and everything
they run at a beautiful just just
beautiful like idling speed they're com
toes but their body is maintained a
balance and Harmony and everything is
great in the body level but as soon as
they become wake then the parameters in
the body all start to change because
it's our Consciousness that is is
creating the the the functions of our
body uh and it's really important for
people understand this is that quantum
physics is the most valid science on
this planet in regard to its theoretical
insights um and the number one principle
in quantum physics is consciousness is
creating our life experience that's the
most important understanding because it
says we're not just a a machine but
we're like a remote control machine
there's a uh an energy field that is
being picked up by each of us that is
different uh the the field that's being
received is different for each person
one of the things that really upset me
for a long time was the fact that I had
great ideas and intentions and I wanted
to manifest them and I thought this is
how it's going to manifest and so I had
all these visions of how things were
going to unfold and then I'd start a
process and it wouldn't unfold and then
it would irritate me because like I've
got to make it work I got to make it
work uh ultimately I started to
recognize when things didn't work it was
possibly because there were better ways
to do it and I wasn't conscious of it
and so what I started to learn over a
period of time was simply this there
there's an old saying there's a means to
an end and the idea well the end is your
destination and of course the means are
how you're going to get to that
destination well of course all of us sit
down and say yeah this is what I want
and then we start to figure out well
this is what I'll do to get to those
ends I'll get to this and I'll get to
this to get to the end what I started to
realize at some point was maybe my
awareness of how to get to the end
wasn't exactly accurate and it turns out
many of the times when things didn't
work and I was like so upset it didn't
work but it turned out oh there was a
better way to get there and I didn't
even know it so the universe was really
facilitating me uh and I wasn't paying
attention I was getting angry at the
universe because like not working the
way I want it to work and then I started
to realize some point was my God maybe
the universe has a better solution than
the one I was even thinking of myself so
I really learned over a period of time
it's very critical insight to help me
get to where I am is to focus on the on
the end what is it I really want put
that Focus together and it's very
critical it's very interesting because a
lot of people have well I would like
this and it's a broad General category
and then at some point it's like what
it's not specific enough you have to
actually say what it is you want uh I'll
always remember I was uh uh looking for
a special shirt to go to a Pink Floyd
concert and and I just all of a sudden
visualized oh it' be neat to have a
Russian shirt you know with a collar
that goes across here and a couple of
buttons down and I thought oh yeah that
would be really great that would be cool
shirt and then I stopped and I was
thinking where the heck do you get a
shirt like that I have no idea in the
world but I thought that would be pretty
good so I figured well I still got to
get something so I drive off to a mall
up near San Francisco and I walk into
the mall and there's a first men's store
over there and I go let's start looking
I have no idea and I walk in and of
course there's this big circular rack of
sale clothes I thought what the hell
it's only a Pink Floyd concert one night
let's see what's in there and I started
going through the rack and lo and behold
oh my God a Russian shirt right in the
middle of everything and it was like the
shock of oh my God there's a Russian
shirt right here the infor the
unfortunate part of
it was I had the picture of a Russian
shirt I said cool I never said what the
color was or anything else I just said
Russian shirt and there was a Russian
shirt color gray no color at all why I
didn't put in the concept of color
Universe said well just give it to him
in Gray uh and it was one of those
things like oh be conscious of what
you're asking for because
the the more detail you put in the more
the universe can manifest a resolution
if you leave a lot of blanks and what
you want then all of a sudden it's like
well it's random whatever fills in the
blanks cuz you never said what you
wanted you can have an idea what you
want and that's important but the most
important part of that just having an
idea is not just have a broad idea I
want X and I go no no what exactly do
you want why go back to the principles
of Science and the principles of science
reveal something very important that
principle of science is this
Consciousness is creating our life
experiences I go well that sounds new
Agy I go no this is not new Agy this is
the primary principle of quantum physics
we are creators this is a fact in fact
uh quantum physics says that but now let
me add one other fact epigenetics says
the same thing because epigenetics says
your Consciousness is controlling your
behavior and your genes and so it's time
to stop for a second going to recognize
where is your Consciousness what are you
thinking about and the idea is start
thinking all those very positive
thoughts but don't try and tell the
universe how it's going to manifest okay
you think of the picture let the
universe get you there and that's the
most important lesson I've learned I'm
not telling the universe how I'm going
to get there I'm just saying Universe
this is where I want to go and then the
universe will take care of it it it's so
powerful it's so wonderful and I never
believed in it for the first 40 50 years
of my life but I can tell you now the
life that I'm manifesting today is a
consequence of just what I said focus on
the end don't tell the universe the
means to get there what are some daily
affirmations you started to implement
when you saw this depressed thoughts
coming in or these self-sabotage
thoughts coming in what did you shift it
with affirmations different thoughts
what did you start to it was just the
awareness a that you know as I said the
very first stop light where I started
all of a sudden listen while I'm waiting
for the light it was like the first time
I tuned in and go what the hell are you
thinking that was the most important
thing because then the habit of not
going there anymore starting to realize
uh oh this why am I thinking it's
negative thing turn around make a
positive statement right now because
that negative one is taking you on the
and just a repetition of this Behavior
become habitual so and habits are great
why no effort I love habits why you
don't even have to think about them they
do it automatically you know so if you
put in these really great habits you can
walk through the day and think anything
you want do anything you want and your
habit if they're good ones will just
guide you perfectly through here without
even being involved with
thinking that's the game the game is
what is heaven to you then program that
that's your life and then guess what the
95% of the day manifesting Heaven while
you're not even thinking about it once
you have identified your programs how
can you change what do you do with them
and that always comes up because that's
the most important question after you
understand how it works the most
important question well how hell do I
change the program and I go this is the
critical
part the conscious mind is creative
which means it can think of anything the
subconscious mind is programmed it's got
habits I go so what I say habits when
you have them it's a habit you do not
want to change a habit which is
important you learned how to walk before
you were two I'm glad you don't change
your habit because you'll forget how to
walk I said nope same program you
learned before too can carry you a
hundred years same program okay habits
do not want to change because if a habit
changes then by definition it's not a
habit so the subconscious mind is habit
mind I say yeah but how do I change I
say there's three ways only that you can
control this number one how' you get the
habits in the first place I say for
seven years my brain was at a low
vibration called Theta which is just
below
Consciousness and Theta is the direct
hypnosis line to the subconscious so
when you're in Theta whatever you're
experiencing at that point can be down
loaded straight into the subconscious I
said well how do you get the Theta I say
interesting every day when you're up at
work you got a high vibration in the in
the brain that's again with the wires on
your head EEG the high vibration is
called beta that's like School room
studying focused
Consciousness when you come home and
relax the vibration goes lower now it
goes into what is called alpha alpha is
calm relaxed consciousness but when you
get really calm and you're really
relaxed guess what Alpha shuts off
you're sleeping when you when Alpha is
off you are sleeping but for the next
period of time right after you fell
asleep the brain is operating in Theta
and then it goes to the lowest vibration
deep sleep Delta so Theta is a period
when your mind goes to sleep it's open
for a little while and Theta is hypnosis
so if you put earphones on and you play
a program at night when you go to bed
every night you go to bed just before
you fall asleep you put the earphones on
you play a program of a program about
health a program how to make money a
program how to be you know uh
relationships PR self-help program okay
at night you put the earphones on when
you go to
bed and as soon as you fall asleep
you're not awake anymore Alpha close
you're in Theta record whatever is
coming in through the earphones is not
going into the conscious mind it's going
deeper into the subconscious it's called
self
hypnosis you put the pro you put the
earphones on you repeat that because
Thea is not a long period after you fall
asleep but if you repeat it every night
you'll get information into the
subconscious so number one self hypnosis
earphones at at night play program that
you want to be true okay and that will
automatically happen this is a
demonstration that and it's fun why you
were sleeping you didn't even have to do
any work you just had to go to sleep and
the work would be automatic so when you
wake up after playing this at night uh
the subconscious will have a new program
and one day you wake up and you're
living the new program without even
playing the tapes anymore it's once it's
in it's in okay so number one is
hypnosis self hypnosis
okay but after age s the brain is not in
HP
nois uh and now Consciousness is working
I said but you can still learn a program
you can learn a habit I say how practice
repetition you want to drive a car well
I'm not getting in a car until you
practice why because it's the practice
that makes the program strong cancer is
a program and you can change cancer by
changing a program but if you believe
the cancer is uh genetically controled
which means you have no control then you
all of a sudden say I'm a victim and
then you want to kill all the cancer
cells because that's the technology and
I go the cancer cells are not the
problem they're the symptom that's the
result of a problem and so you can kill
all the damn cancer cells you want but
you never got to the cause of the
problem the cause of the problem was
something that caused a cell to become
cancer and all of a sudden we go back to
the Consciousness and the programming
and the same thing diabetes type
to 100% environment 100%
environment and and I go so why this
important because as you've been talking
about let's get away from the idea that
I am a genetically programmed individual
no I'm a
Creator and I'm creating this and the
emphasis is how through the blood the
chemistry two parts
nutrition and
information and the idea about it is
this if you fail on the nutrition it's
like the machine will break down that's
what the function is if you don't take
care of the car it breaks down when you
look in the junkyard and you see all the
cars piled up I say is that because they
were built wrong genetically incorrect I
go no no it was driver error that put
those cars into the junkyard it's driver
error that's responsible for
99% of disease on this planet 90% of
health issues on this planet 90% it's
probably more is due to stress what does
that mean I say that the chemistry of
stress in the
blood negatively impacts the body
originally just make a difference why
would the body have a problem with you
know dealing with the stress because I
said when the body is evolving what
stress did we actually have I give
example a sabertooth tiger is chasing us
I said that's a moment of stress folks
and I said what happens the stress
hormones go into the body and they
prepare you for running fight or flight
then you get away from that tiger and
guess
what no more stress so how long did that
take 10 15 minutes okay I go so when we
had stress in our history and in our
Evolution it was only for a very short
period of time just temporarily get the
body ready for fight or flight just
temporary but today stress is every day
24 hours a day 365 days a year all of us
are under stress do you have enough
money will you be able to get health
care will you be able to pay the rent my
god there stress all the time this is
why we have a health care crisis okay
and I say why the chemistry of stress
and I'll explain it in three steps this
is the result of stress so you
understand why are the problem comes
from when you're in fight or flight your
mission is to run away from the
saber-tooth tiger and I go so what does
that mean I say well you need all the
energy in your body to run away from the
tiger and I said well what systems do I
need to run away from the tiger I said
well mainly your arms and legs because
that's going to carry you away I say
okay and I say so why is that important
I said because that's where you need the
blood why the blood is the energy to
make those arms and legs move so the
more blood you have in the muscles uh
and the arms and legs the more powerful
you are to run away from the the problem
okay so I go so where was the blood if
there was no stress and I go oh what
else is in the body take the arms and
legs off the body what do you got left
you've got the gut the viscera you got
the guts and I say well what do they do
I say oh they maintain the body they
clean it filter it put nutrients into it
remove waste products replace the cells
that are damaged by blah blah blah I go
oh so the gut is where all the
maintenance of my body is being taken
care of and I go yes now here's the
point you're being chased by a
saber-tooth tiger you think you need to
do all the work on the body right now
maybe it could just like have an air
raid siren or something say look stop
work we're going we're going to run I
say well what happens and here's what it
is the stress hormones cause the blood
vessel in the gut to constrict tight I
go what does that mean it pushes the
blood from the gut to the arms and legs
that's the one I need to run with yeah
but what does it mean about the gut I
say it stops
functioning maintenance of the body is
out taking care of the system is out why
the energy is getting ready to run so
you moment the stress hormones are in
you stop maintaining the body number two
and this is the big one you ready stress
hormones shut off off the immune system
oh yeah I say why is that important well
if you've ever been sick you might have
known maybe you didn't even have the
energy to get out of bed when the immune
system is operating like that it uses so
much energy you probably can't even move
sometimes I go yep so I say you're being
chased by a saber-tooth tiger you have a
bacterial
infection how do you want to split the
energy how much energy you want to fight
that bacteria back or how much energy
you want to run away from the tiger let
me help you with the answer you want all
the energy to run away from the tiger so
stress hormones listen to this stress
hormones shut off the immune system to
conserve energy to escape the
stress oh my God that means the more
stressed you're under the less effective
your immune system is because the stress
hormones are shutting it
down I said there were three things and
the third one is also very important
when you're in a fight or flight it's
not time to think and I say what does
that mean I say well thinking is a very
slow process I ask you to think about
something you go oh I go when you're
running away from the tiger you don't
have to go oh you don't have time for
that you got to run so stress hormones
shut off thinking 5% of the day we move
toward wishes desires what we want even
you know the addict is like yeah I don't
want this this is not my life I really
want this and and all that and then I
say yeah but that only works 5% of the
day 95% of the day you're coming from
The Habit yeah but the Habit was other
people's behavior that you put into the
subconscious first and so 95% of the day
you're not operating from your wishes
and desires you're operating from a
program sure okay but now here's the
catch and then we'll get we'll get on to
it and that is this by definition if I
am thinking all of a sudden I say what
am I doing next Wednesday go to my head
I'm thinking about what I'm doing uh
what's on Wednesday by definition I'm
not paying attention to what's going on
so that doesn't mean like you're walking
down the street you have a thought and
then you freeze while the thought
happens and then after the thought then
you start walking back down the street
again no if you're walking down the
street you have a thought the moment you
have a conscious mind engaged in thought
it the functions are defaulted to the
subconscious program so in other words I
know how to walk that's a habit I
learned that so I don't need my
conscious mind to tell me how to walk so
my conscious mind goes in thought I'm
still walking so whatever behavior I'm
doing driving a car I I don't have to
pay attention to what's going on when
I'm driving the car I mean the the joke
when I lecture about is I say look you
know I've been in a car with a passenger
we get so engaged in a conversation my
conscious mind is tied up with the
conversation and then all of a sudden I
look out the window of the car and it
Dawns on me I haven't paid attention to
the road for the last five minutes how
did I get home yeah and and here here's
what the KNE part is well look driving
is once you practice and learn how to
drive practice makes habit habit means
that the subconscious mind doesn't need
you to explain how to drive and what to
watch out for subconscious mind's
already got a program Rory mooy who uh
he was leading the Masters Golf
Tournament a few years back he had a big
lead and you know this just one example
I'm not having to go Rory this is just
is common in all sports where um people
almost self implode and for a few
holes like he could barely swing the
golf club what was really interesting is
as I always sort of reading a lot of bit
trying to figure out what what's going
on here it's this conscious subconscious
again where he knows how to drive the
golf ball you know better than most
people on the planet yes so he's playing
usually from his subconscious the
patterns are in he knows how to shake
the ball right to left left to right
whatever but in that moment where it's
like oh man I'm leading the Masters I
need to be really careful now he's
trying to think you know well certainly
this is what people say I don't know
what was in his mind but you're almost
overthinking you're now trying to
control something that you could
naturally do as you say driving yeah if
you were thinking about when do I put
the clutch down or what timing is it
with the accelerator you know if you if
you drive a manual it's it's the same
kind of thing isn't it absolutely but
it's fact really what when he's playing
the game he's playing it in the
conscious mind in the sense that he has
a vision I'm going to hit this ball and
it's going to go into that hole over
there very important because you there's
a destination and there's a means to
that destination it turns out and this
is really most important is if you focus
on the destination and not on the means
let the system which is so powerful to
it it will get there without you telling
it how to get there but when you start
to interfere and say okay now I got to
make sure I swing it right my head's
level my grip is right and all of a
sudden you you're putting all this
details in it's like no don't focus on
the details you forgot what the end was
the end was the ball is supposed to go
over without there and so that starts to
come in because now you're trying to
control everything with your you know
with this manual control and it's like
no uh you don't have to have the manual
control a matter of fact that gets in
the way yeah the body knows what you
want you don't have to tell it how to
get there that's a big issue in our
lives because uh I want to be successful
how oh I got to do this I got to do this
and I say oh you're you're planning all
these things uh and you're your
conscious mind is not even any the
subconscious is a million times more
powerful a computer than the conscious
mind so I say you're going to take this
little small conscious mind and try to
run the bigger computer it's like that
doesn't work let go of the control and
this is the whole thing I mean it's a i
it just came to my mind a lot of people
say let go let God or something like
there's some phrase that people always
say and I go well that's actually the
way to do it focus on what you want but
don't try and tell the universe how it's
going to happen don't tell them that I'm
going to do this and this is going to
happen I go no you just focus on what
you want the intelligence of the super
computer the subconscious super
Compu uh it will handle it unless you
put your hands into the machine I said
keep your hands out of the machine focus
on where that Ball's going to go I mean
he already practiced remember I said we
did The Habit we did the practice
whether you're driving the car or
hitting the golf ball practice practice
you don't think about the details of
driving when you're driving you know
they just automatically you could have
conversation you could be off in thought
and you're still driving the car
Consciousness is creating your reality
if you put a picture of fear into your
reality then your biology beh Behavior
will manifest things to be afraid of
because this is a a short statement but
to me it's the most powerful one simple
and short it goes like this the function
of the mind is to create coherence
between your beliefs and your reality if
I have a negative belief the function of
my mind is to manifest Behavior to
experience those negative realities if I
have positive beliefs then the function
of my mind is to manifest the posit POS
experience but we get programmed with so
many negative beliefs and that takes
away our power because we're not
focusing on the beautiful things we're
focusing on the fear what are you afraid
of there are three ways to change belief
okay self-hypnosis ear phones on at
night repetition create a new habit and
third one energy psychology which allows
you to rewrite an existing program in
minutes uh and we need to do this why
because if you haven't noticed it and
you haven't looked out the window the
world's falling apart I go and why is it
falling apart and the answer is because
we're facing what is called the six mass
extinction of Life the web of life is
collapsing I go then why is the web of
Life collapsing the answer is human
behavior I go
oh we don't want the web to collapse we
have to change a
behavior and this is what the world is
experiencing at this time the all over
the world is bringing to light the fact
that these behaviors we're fighting and
violently with are behaviors that have
taken us out of heaven and put our
Consciousness into a world that we're
experiencing which is falling apart you
want to make a world of heaven then you
changed the program and then you could
have Heaven it's your belief system that
that creates this you fell in love
because you stopped playing your program
and you created heaven I say well guess
what heaven was always there except the
damn program gotten away so you want
heaven on
Earth don't play the program stay
mindful or B rewrite the existing
program and put Heaven on Earth programs
in there and then 95% of the day you'll
be playing that the movie The Matrix
everyone thinks science fiction I go no
no that's a documentary everybody got
programmed that's a fact that's a
biological reality but what was
interesting they always say well there's
a red pill and if you take the red pill
you get out of the program and I go
guess what
almost everybody in our audience is
taking that red pill at one time changed
their life yes when was that it turns
out science has recognized that when you
fall in love you stop playing the
programs and you start creating from
your conscious mind wishes and desires
are conscious mind and so once you let
go of the program and you start creating
wishes and desires it's called the
honeymoon yes who created this heaven on
Earth experience and I go and here's the
inside story that Micha has been telling
you for years but I can now tell you you
could have that every day for every day
of your whole life we created that and
if you understand you created it then
you can say well why don't I create it
tomorrow and I go you can create it
every day that's the beautiful part 95%
of our behavior is coming from sub below
Consciousness and we're the ones that
can't see it when we play it but
everybody else of course is uh seeing
exactly what we're doing so the whole
idea is are you living the life you want
or are you Liv living the life you've
been programmed and the answer
unfortunately is most of us are living a
life we've been programmed and and the
programming comes from other people so
it's not our lives the reason let's give
a reason why programming occurs okay uh
the brain is a computer most powerful
computer that humans have ever
experienced but it has parallels to
computers and number one is this um in
the old days when you would buy a
computer before they put the programs in
you could bring it home brand new
computer plug it in push start boots up
screens on and I say do something and
people well no I can't do anything say
you got a brand new computer now first
you have to put programs into a computer
before you can use that computer the
brain of a of a human is the same thing
uh the screen lights up in the last
trimester of pregnancy it's ready but
there are no programs so the first seven
years of a child's life is the brain is
not operating at the higher level of
Consciousness higher level higher
vibration that's we talked about we put
wires on a person's head electroen
cograph read brain function a child up
through seven is not operating at
Consciousness except for a little bit
it's primarily operating at a lower
vibration called Theta and I said well
what is Theta I say it's expressed as
imagination so that's how uh children
can have a tea party and they pour
nothing into the cup and then they drink
the nothing and then they explain how
that was the best tea they ever had or a
child rides a broom saying it's a horse
in the child's mind that is not a broom
it's a it's a horse but it's mixing
imagination and reality but Theta is
hypnosis and the significance of that is
children have to learn how to become a
member of a family the rules member of a
community the rules I go how how can an
infant a young kid learn these rules
they can't go to school they can't read
the book and all that and I say you
don't have to Nature provided Theta
hypnosis so that they can observe the
parent the family and the community just
observe their behavior and download
those as programs age seven then that's
when they start to become more conscious
and engaging themselves first seven
years is programming but after age 7 95%
of your life is coming from that program
so if you can program the child for the
first seven years then the rest of the
life of that child is actually an
expression of that program I was given
an opportunity to go to San
Francisco and have a big presentation at
a big conference on energy and crystals
and stuff like that and I thought well
there's going to be an audience there
energy and crystals like okay this
everything I'm talking about in biology
I was so excited and I thought this is
my great opportunity and it was like
like 3 months before and I thought okay
I'll I'm going to work on this and then
I just let it go I let it go and now we
getting to a month before and I said I
got to work on my what's my seminar
going to be what's my seminar and all I
had in my head was okay this was new Agy
kind of thing so I thought well back
then what the heck was new Agy I said oh
that's where they wear all white white
shirts and white pants and a white vest
white clothes you know and that they're
so delicate and they speak in a very
quiet tone and they're so new Agy and
that really wasn't me I was like the
bull in the china shop you know it's
like hey and it goes no no that's I got
to calm down I got to be cool I'm going
to present this in a new age fashion so
I tried to formulate at a new age me to
present this well now it's about a week
before this conference it's like my new
age me has not come up with any idea of
how to present this and then it started
to get closer it was just a few days
away I'm going to go to S Francisco I
like oh my God I don't have a talk and I
just said forget it let me just be me I
just want to talk the way I want to talk
I'm not going to conform to be some new
age Guru that's not me I'm a science guy
and I'm going to say what I want to say
and finally in that moment it was just a
couple of days before all of a sudden I
said that's it no more new age let's
let's write this and the moment I let go
of some Persona I was supposed to be and
just said n I'm just going to be me all
of a sudden the word started coming out
I can remember I grabbed a yellow pad
and I had a pen and the word started
coming so fast as soon as I said stop
being New Age Guy start being Bruce the
words start coming page after page I was
writing I had like four or five pages of
notes notes notes notes like after all
those months it was sort of like okay it
was a little constipated in my
Consciousness you know but it all of a
sudden freed up and it's why I am not
them I'm
me and try to act like somebody else
took away everything I was and that was
at the point that said oh my God I'm
going to have I'm not going to alter who
I am I Love This research I'm not going
to tailor it for for that audience and
it was so wonderful because there were 3
months where it was just loging back of
my head back in my head yeah I got to do
this I do this like didn't want to do it
why cuz at some level the first thing
was I'm going to be somebody else I'm
going to be Mr New Age
guy the moment I let go of being
somebody else and became me then all the
words came down here's the simple truth
the first 40 years was struggle
life when I did the py and all that
stuff the last 30 years has been the
most enjoyment I could ever imagine in
life that I even wrote a book called the
honeymoon effect because the the harmony
of what love brings into the world you
know and people in a honeymoon it's like
heaven on Earth and I say for 30 years
I've been living heaven on Earth and and
every aspect of my life is so beautiful
and why I changed the limiting program
through the process of
py and when I put in programs that gave
me uh the values I wanted the joy which
is so really important about it is I
didn't have to work on it once the
program was in there the subconscious
running 95% of the day automatically
without my even participating
consciously I was Finding heaven without
even making an effort to get there mhm
and I am living in this Most Wonderful
Life
no doctors no pharmaceutical drugs uh no
insurance you either no me either why
should I spend the money for insurance I
haven't had Insurance since 1992 yeah I
haven't either uh and and the fact is
what who needs it I'm not I'm not
planning to do that right and the idea
is what we really ultimately come down
to is life isn't a bunch of accidents
that we move through life is a bunch of
creations and if your life is a struggle
uh we always have a tendency to say oh
the universe is against me or something
like that victim mentality I'm a victim
I can't oh it's out of my control it's
that's the problem not me and once you
understand the basis of the new biology
and the psych process you start to
recognize why I am a co-creator of my
life and if my programs are not really
good then my life will not be really
good changing those programs and here I
am today with you and look how beautiful
this woman
Sparkles and shines why when we clean up
the the problems that we acquired in our
development mhm then life comes to us
you don't even have to go out and Chase
it anymore and that is the 100%
difference first 40 years I'm going to
go get that success last 30 years open
the door oh here you are thank you very
much yeah yeah so uh all I can say is
the most exciting experience in my life
was to Take Back Control Bruce do you
have uh in your work a general
perspective on or a definition or a way
that you look at
addiction well basically what I have to
understand about biology is that
throughout Evolution um biological
systems are given information in
response to how they how they deal with
the world around them we call them
emotions Sensations feelings symptoms
Etc like that one of the major aspects
is this is that nature is designed uh
two senses of pain and pleasure uh as a
way of teaching an organism to go in the
right direction in other words we're
smart we go to school we learn you know
cross the street look both ways and all
that kind of stuff like that but uh you
got smaller lower forms of life animals
that are moving through the world how do
they know where to go and where not to
go how to to do the right thing to stay
alive well nature uh has endowed them
with a sense of feeling and the
significance about that is we are given
two completely opposite senses one is
pain and one is pleasure when pleasure
is uh received by an organism or
perceived by an organism it really
represents that you're doing the right
thing and that's why nature encourages
you says look this is really good go
this way but when you start to do
something that threatens your survival
or it's really not supportive uh we
receive a sensation of pain and that's
Nature's way of saying look this is
threatening to you this is you know
inappropriate behavior whatever it is do
something different uh and it's kind of
interesting because uh in our
civilization and throughout history that
was manipulated a bit by by the original
Church uh which looked at uh pleasure as
negative and pain as positive which is
like complete turnaround of the table of
biology some confusing messages there
absolutely but it it it really causes a
a profound um conflict in our biology
when our biology is telling us we're
doing something right gives us pleasure
and then our psychology is saying no no
that's wrong don't do that uh then we
have a conflict between programming and
biology and so basically what I see is
this is that when we find ourselves in
trauma and problems uh a we try to seek
a way to get out if you can't seek a way
to get out then you actually do some
kind of other Behavior or something else
to uh to lessen the pain because uh if
you can't move and you're stuck in pain
then what are you supposed to do just
live in that well in our level of
cognition and awareness we can put in
some other behavior and and and and then
actually uh override the the current
experience so what we have to recognize
is when people really are generally
dealing with an addiction problem
they're really first trying to overcome
some kind of pain in their life or
threat to their survival or their
existence and then choose another
alternative Behavior unfortunately the
alternative behaviors don't necessarily
take you out of the problem so you stay
in the problem uh but even though you're
trying to get mentally out of the
problem knowledge is power and lack of
knowledge is a lack of power when people
don't know that they're involved with
their own life and their own genetics
and their own behavior because they're
programmed to be the victim then they
become a victim because they have no
knowledge of this and and what you're
doing what I'm doing is let let's wake
up you are powerful if you understand
how this works and if you don't
understand how it works you just say no
it's not me I'm not in control and and
people walk away feeling like there's
nothing I can do the genes are
controlling this and I don't control the
genes I go well that's the story that's
wrong and when people are allowed to
walk away from uh a medical practitioner
with that belief then that practitioner
is no way has help that patient because
the idea is this as you said I've got to
help them get a better attitude when
they walk out of this building I have to
give them more power so that they have
more power because if they walk out
saying there's nothing I can do then the
game is over at that point what is
happening right now in the world in
society that you see where things are
are ramping up or are
they and why is it more more important
now than ever go ahead okay uh we're in
the process of of an evolutionary
upheaval at this very this very time
moment and the upheaval is due to crisis
and we see the crisis around the world
whether it's economic religious racial
whatever you want I say those are trees
in a forest and I say if you get back a
little further away you can see the
bigger crisis is uh we are facing an
imminent Extinction of human
civilization uh and and this is
real and the public uh has has been made
aware of it a long time ago and then
sort of disappeared that we are facing
what is called the six mass extinction
of Life on this planet which means five
times uh there were previous mass
extinctions and and the point about we
always think evolution is one continuous
you know from beginning to end it's like
no it starts stops breaks starts again
stops breaks and it's done five times
the last uh mass extinction 66 million
years ago when the dinosaurs were here
and a comet hit near Mexico up ended the
web of life and then all of a sudden 75%
of uh all species
disappeared uh when that after that
comment uh but today we're in What's
called the six mass extinction and why
we're bringing in here Abraham and Tara
is basically because science has
recognized for the last oh my God 15
years or more that human civilization
human
behavior is undermining the Web of Life
leading to our own Extinction
uh and just is there a number I'll give
you an interesting number the uh World
Wildlife Foundation in 1970 took a
survey how many animals on planet Earth
uh they recently redid the survey 2third
of the entire animal population of the
planet has disappeared since the first
time they did it uh we're losing species
of organism faster than in some previous
as I said five mass extinctions
significance is this human behavior is
now has been Rec recognized as the cause
of this we are undermining our
environment thinking that we are you
know a dominant in control of the
environment now we are the environment
you you you know uh you know the
Grandeur of human thinking is a weak can
control and dominate danger is like well
how's that working the answer is facing
mass extinction in the next few decades
period so we have to change Behavior
that's why when I say some of my
lectures I say okay how many people in
here have read a self-help book and all
the hands go up I say okay now how many
of you your lives changed after you read
the salel book all the hands go back
down I said what's the issue and the
issue is this you educated your
conscious mind the creative mind by
reading a book but the subconscious mind
doesn't learn that way and it's very
important it's resistant to change why
if I learned a habit I don't want it to
change every day if I learned how to
walk I don't want to have to relearn how
to walk all the time I if I learned how
to do it then fine so that basically
says then the subconscious mind is
resistant to change I say number one so
what so what happens how does it do it
like if you're if you're sober years I
have to go back and say well how did you
educate the conscious mind the
subconscious mind in the first place I
go first seven years hypnosis that's
what the brain was in Thea it was just
downloading programs bypassing
Consciousness conscious our conscious
Minds did not filter the download of the
programs and say good program bad
program why conscious mind wasn't
working when the downloads were going so
I just got programs conscious mind
wasn't even there doesn't even have any
idea of it so excuse me the next issue
is this okay your brain is in hypnosis
for first seven years but your
subconscious still learns programs after
you're seven I say how does it learn it
then I go oh
habituation repetition repeat the
behavior over and over and over again
whether that's a healthy Behavior or an
unhealthy Behavior you'll learn a new
pattern depending on what you practice
absolutely because the the the function
of that mind is to take pattern that is
played over and over again and then
acquired that's why look you want to
learn how to drive a car practice how to
drive a car you want go back this one
this a learning our ABCs go back to your
childhood how long did it take you to
get from A to Z the answer was how many
times did you start AB b
c a c d
e and then you repeated it you repeated
it you repeated it and finally you got
the Z what was the result I never had to
do it again I habituated it because I
repeated it over and over and over again
that's how I learned how many times did
I repeat the times table in school uh
whatever issue on a job I learn to do
the job I learn how to communicate all
these different things so uh basically
how'd you do that repetition a lack of
knowledge is a lack of power and I said
you're suffering out here because you
feel you have no power and if you really
understand the biology that we're
talking about and the spirituality that
you're talking about and you start to
recognize it you recognize oh my God you
are so powerful and yet you have a
belief of victim and since belief
controls it no matter how powerful you
are if your belief is your a victim then
you are a victim and we have been a
victimized by beliefs that are incorrect
and uh uh and if we adjust the science
it Auto atically then comes right
together with the whole spiritual
message that agape and my brother
Reverend here uh have been providing for
years uh but there's a scientific
context to it because a lot of people go
well this a scientific I go yes it
is I mean I mean where where are those
flawed beliefs that that we've been
living under all these years there four
of them and two of them are actually
part of darwinian theory which I'll
mention but the first one that's really
important is people have been
programming the belief that the genes
they inherited at conception are
programming the rest of their life the
the genes we didn't select them as far
as we know if you don't like the
characteristics you can't change these
genes and then we add on top of that we
say and the genes turn on and off by
themselves and all of a sudden you start
to realize then I'm not running my life
the genes are running my life oh my God
there's cancer in the family and their
genes are going I'm going to get a
cancer Gene I'm and I said what's the
belief you already got the belief I'm
going to get cancer I go this is trouble
right there right right right right this
little sidebar because I love this
sidebar there's not one gene that causes
cancer cancer is not caused by a gene
cancer is caused by disharmony in your
life uh unresolved anger is the bigest
one uh feeling lost left out you know
not part of something is another one
that separates you and I want people to
understand that because so many people
say oh I've got this cancer and the gene
doesn't I'm just a victim back here and
the jeans took this and jeans made this
I go stop you are co-creating with those
genes the gene does not turn on and off
and the gene does not control things the
gene responds to the environment and if
your perception of the environment is
not in Harmony and support of your life
that disharmony is what can activate a
gene a gene is a blueprint just like in
an architect's office and I mentioned I
say you go into an architect office and
she's working on a blueprint you ask her
you say hey is your blue blueprint on or
off and she'd look at you like what are
you crazy it's a blueprint there on and
off I go yes DNA is a blueprint to make
the proteins of the body it cannot turn
itself on and off you need an
architect Consciousness mind is
architect right that turns the genes on
and can modify the readout of the genes
Consciousness is controlling your
genetic
activity when when people follow the
fate of a child adopted into a family
where there's cancer they find that the
adopted child will get the same family
cancer at the same probability as any of
the natural siblings so an adopted child
picks up that gets that cancer but
here's the point the adopted child came
from totally different genetics so it
was not the genetics that pushed that
cancer it was being adopted into a
family where the programming was not
giving them uh wholeness health
happiness uh it's just U stressful very
stressful programming and as you said
stress American Psychological
Association recognizes 90% of doctor
visits are stress related
visits and the we don't focus on the
stress that's like oh a side thing I say
no it's not a side thing it's the number
one thing that is coming from the top
down uh and the
genes genes are blueprints to make the
proteins of the body 100,000 different
protein proteins like building blocks
okay proteins are complex molecules and
they wear out proteins wear out all the
time so you have to replace them I said
well how do you replace this complex
molecule and the answer is DNA is a
blueprint to make a protein I go so what
I go well you go into an architect's
office and she's working on a blueprint
and I say well ask her is your blueprint
honor off she would look at go what are
you talking about it's a blueprint it's
no on and off I go precisely gen cannot
turn themselves on and off they don't
self-actualize they're controlled by
environmental signals and all of a
sudden oh my god well if the environment
is controlling this then your
programming in the environment your
lifestyle in the environment and all
these other things now become the
primary controlling factor of your genes
not the genes and we have to let go
because when I was programming the
doctors that oh jeans turn on and off
and all that stuff I was programming
mean that people are victims because as
I said as far as you know you didn't
pick the genes you can't change them
they operate by themselves and so we
were programming victim and then it
turns out the new science of epigenetics
it's not victim you're the one that's
actually controlling it with your
behavior if my thoughts are distorted
because of animal Soul when I broadcast
these thoughts I'm not activating what I
want I'm activating what the program
wants and I started to realize that
because the magnetic field as you said
is shaping our experiences in this world
at this point and that's what you can
read with Magneto andil graph you're
reading these fields which are your
thoughts and then I started to realize
when the field is being mainly run by
the animal
Soul I'm not controlling that that was
the automatic program that's a program
that's not me that's program and I
realized I could observe me doing the
program but there's a point like you
recognize there's a point you say wait a
minute I'm the controller I don't want
that program I want to use my human soul
to run the
show and as you said same thing once you
start coming from the human soul you
override the animal soul and that's when
you become the Creator and because of
our creation not only is information
coming in but as the Magneto andil graph
shows the information going out and I
say it affects the world we're living in
okay that's the experience you have now
but it also goes back to the original
spirit and this is the karma part where
my life experience has
distorted my spiritual broadcast and I
say 'well how how do I get back and I
say it's very simple you just have to
know who you are and this is what you
said and it's true most people have no
idea who they are they think they're
this physical body and I said that's
what I used to think when I was
conventional science but once I
understood the physics and the role of
energy and Consciousness and spirit the
game for me I said wait a minute I don't
want to be animal soul I want to be
Bruce's soul I want brucees to create
this not the not the program from mother
and father and culture I don't want that
one I want one and like you I started to
recognize well wait I can change I can
now I want to take the control now I
want to put my hands back on the
steering wheel I want to drive this I
don't want the program to drive this you
know the cell phone that you have in
your hand yeah you can drive it by
talking into it but it also can work by
itself because it's got program and I
think that you and I have this
information that we've been trying to
present to the world to say take back
the
control because you're more than this
body well I could live in a perfectly
healthy happy environment that will
support me but if I perceive it's a
negative environment then my cells
inside my body do not know that it is a
healthy environment they only see
the perception that I send to them and
this is why perception becomes so
important is because the cells are not
directly touching the environment and
depend on the nervous system's
interpretation to adjust their biology
so if I change my perception my mind
change my belief about life I change the
signals that are going in and adjusting
the function of the cell the point is
very very significant and that is this
I'm not a victim of my genes because I
uh by my ability to change my
environment and by my ability to change
my perception of the environment have
the ability to control my genetic
activity I'm not a victim of my heredity
I'm a master of my genetic activity well
how do you change a program that was the
issue not how you change the conscious
mind how do you change the subconscious
mind because it doesn't learn conscious
mind learns by just whatever you read
the book I learned it okay uh
subconscious mind doesn't learn that way
I say how does it learn I say well in
the first seven years that's when I said
the programming went in the brain wasn't
functioning at the higher level of
Consciousness it was actually a little
lower that was called Theta the
vibration the imagination and all that
that's hypnosis okay so the first way we
learned programs was hypnosis because
the the the function of the brain wasn't
it was at a high at a low you know lower
vibration uh some people might remember
the old days when hypn theapy they
they'd have a watch and the
hypnotherapist said you know swing the
watch back and forth and they would say
you're getting tired you're getting
tired uh and what was the point when you
get tired you lower the vibration of the
brain and the moment you fall asleep
actually consciously the next level of
activity of the brain is Theta before it
goes down to the lowest vibration Delta
sleep so every night when you go to bed
there's a period just after you close
eyes and you're essentially disconnected
for a moment your brain is operating in
Theta well Theta is hypnosis okay so I
said well that's how you you your brain
was in Theta during that childhood
period as predominantly now you're an
adult I said yeah but you have Theta
every night when you go to bed so I said
what can you do and this is the old
story you've heard people do it you put
a pair of earphones on at night you play
a program that you want to be true in
your life you and while you're awake you
might hear the program but it's the
moment you fall asleep the conscious
mind shut off but the subconscious mind
is now in record Theta so whatever is
coming through the earphones at that
moment after you fall asleep you don't
hear it but the subconscious mind is
hearing it and downloading it in a state
of theta so the first way of changing a
belief system is to get into Theta uh
and this is called self- hypnosis put
the earphones on play the program
programs for health happiness love joy
whatever and just go to sleep which is
really cool cuz you don't have any
there's no studying here you just play
the program I think this is one of the
best things that we both can do right
now is to help people recognize how
truly powerful they are even though
they've been programmed saying I'm a
victim I say no you're not and there's a
science behind it and that's why I love
talking with you because there's the
spiritual part which I never was
spiritual for 40 years I was a Science
Guy jeans chromosomes blah blah blah and
then in the study of the cells the cells
taught me that we're not even in here
we're broadcast playing through here and
and when you understand why which was
which blew my mind because he I wasn't
spiritual and all of a sudden I said oh
my goodness the cells have little
antennas on them and each of us has a
different set of these antennas which
are receiving a broadcast yes in physics
you might say the word field which is uh
let me Define it invisible moving forces
that influence the physical world and I
go
same definition for Spirit invisible
moving forces influence the physical
world I said oh my God quantum physics
is revealed to us that we're this energy
spirit and we come in and play through
the body and our each of our bodies have
a different sets of antennas so no two
people get the same station and all of a
sudden I realize oh my God you know
after 40 some years of not even
believing in it in two minutes I turn
around and go of course everything is
spiritual the meaning of it for me
Michael was so great because you know
what happened fear you had you had a
kind of an
instantaneous like Epiphany it just
changed your life the lightning hit me
yeah and and what was interesting within
seconds I lost
fear because I understand that because
the greatest fear people have is death
yes what if you don't die because the
field is always here whether the body
which I call the television set you're
watching the Bruce show on the
television set here but the bru show is
a broadcast being picked up and played
through the show and I realized uh you
can't die you're not even in here right
where the energy around
here and then but then you know being a
inquisitive scientist I I remember I'll
never forget it I sat there just like oh
my God there's a spirit and there's a
body and a spirit and my science mind
said why not just be a spirit why have a
body and then I found out I had what I
referred to as Jewish comedian cells
because I I asked a question well I have
both a body and a spirit and the cells
answered with a question that came right
up in my head and the answer is like
it's so profound and so funny I said why
have a SPID in the body and the and the
cell said Bruce if you're just a spirit
what does chocolate taste
like now you have to take that one in
for a little bit and realize something
is that this
body translates energy environment into
pictures and sounds and smells and
feelings uh and all these things and I
go oh my God we came here to experience
life we become less
intelligent when we're
afraid and then I say well look at the
world today it's chaos it's fear I mean
the co thing scared everybody so much
they said don't even talk to anybody put
your mask on keep away from everybody
the business is shut down but I said oh
my God this is
fear and I go that is the result and
that happens inside the body everything
shuts down that would keep you going
when you're in a state of fear and this
is why over 90% of illness is directly
related to the stress that we're living
in in this world and you might say well
what about cancer I'm going to tell you
most important fact is listen to this
there is not one gene that c cuses
cancer ah what about all the cancer
genes I say no those are genes that will
support the cancer but there are not
genes that cause the cancer I go wait
there's no genes that cause cancer I say
no I said then what's the cause you
ready disharmony in the biology remember
your cells are a community think about
it this way if you have a a a bad leader
of the community bad president or prime
minister I go then what happens I say
there's not happiness in the
community
disharmony and I said what if you have a
good leader and I said then the
community is right behind them
supporting them so I said but your mind
is the leader I say is your mind sending
good information I'm healthy I'm happy
I'm strong I'm in love I'm enjoying my
life or is your mind sending be careful
be afraid watch out somebody's going to
get you're not going to have this I go
what's the difference and I go the
difference is that stress
hormone it uh shuts down your
maintenance of your body it shuts down
your immune system and it shuts down
your intelligence and when you stop
using your intelligence that's what's
controlling the community of 50 trillion
cells so all of a sudden it becomes
important to
recognize your Consciousness your
thoughts are the government
what I really would like to let people
know is while the world looks totally
crazy at this moment this is a very
important part of our Evolution and the
reason is uh human civilization has been
destroying the planet that we are now
facing what is called the six mass
extinction of Life on this planet and
and since we are the ones that are
causing it it is based on our culture
and the way we've been living and not
treating nature with love and respect
that we are losing contact and so what
we see is breaking down is an old way of
life that has actually caused the
problems and that we're facing a new
Evolution and to do that you you can't
build it on the foundation where the
problem is so when you see the
foundation breaking I'm Not Afraid
matter of fact I'm so like yeah it's
faking because that's the only way we
can build a new one so I just want
people to realize when you see the world
falling apart it's not the bad news it's
actually the good news because if we
kept it the same
way Extinction is looming right in front
of us and I'm not talking a thousand
years I'm talking of decades and so um
welcome to the evolution start taking
care of ourselves so all of a sudden
it's like instead of being out on the
road okay uh you know I I I look at what
I eat quite differently uh I'm feeding
50 trillion cells in my community and uh
I like to you know I know for the
biological reason of giving them the
healthiest finest uh nourishment
possible because as a person who used to
grow cell tissue culture uh culture
medium is the equivalent of blood and we
grow cells in it and if you compromise
the composition of that culture medium
in any way the cells will get sick and
die and so we have to learn how to take
care of that so people are learning a
little bit about that we also have to uh
uh understand vitamins and supplements
are really good for us especially
vitamin C is great for immune system a
lot of it it's really good uh and then
start to uh also look at maybe uh which
I'm going to go do right after this is
go climb a mountain right here in the
out across the road because I need to
get some exercise every now and then
reprogramming my subconscious mind to do
what get rid of or replace the
disempowering programs with empowering
ones and I go here's the benefit here's
the benefit of it once the new program
is in you don't have to even make any
effort why you haven't made any effort
to get where you are right
now it's your subconscious been doing
all the time so I said well what if you
put all good stuff in your subconscious
I go well then without any effort you
will have all the good things that you
were looking for health and happiness
and relationships and stuff like that
and that's the
destination because you got to get out
of I'm a victim everyone thinks they're
a victim I go well what does victim mean
powerless and so if I'm I'm telling you
I'm powerless and what do you think is
going to happen and as you went like
that before the answer is this I'll sell
you some power I'll I'll be the
pharmaceutical you want some power I'll
sell you this drug okay I'm this guy
I'll sell you that you'll get more power
more power what did they do they made us
into consumers why I can't do it I'm the
victim but they can get it for me how
much do I pay them I say well hey
religion was based on all this stuff
yeah how how much does it cost me not to
go to hell well 10% of your salary was
tithing I go for what they're going to
protect me from going to hell uh you
know the the spiritual people I go why
am I paying them
10% I can I could create my own Heaven
which I did and all of a sudden it says
stop disempowering me that is the
message who does it go to it goes to the
medical community that you disempower me
by telling me what my future is going to
be and I buy into the belief in that
first seven years that you control my
health I don't control my health I'd go
to the doctor
the and my program is doctor knows about
my health I don't the doctor says you're
going to die in 3 months then guess what
you just put in your brain a program of
in 3 months I will be dead and you will
I say will you die of the cancer they
said you had and I go nope you can you
die from the belief of the three months
because when they start doing autopsies
on people that we know they were going
to die in 3 months of this cancer and
they start finding but they didn't die
from the cancer what' they die from the
belief belief controls your life if you
believe you're going to die you can die
just from the belief humans are
destroying the environment because we're
voracious we eat everything out there
take the trees the plants the soil the
we we take everything voracious and we
pushed it to the situation now that the
uh nature can't support us because we
we're breaking the web of life life down
and it's asking us to change and I say
you know let me give a parallel here
that makes
sense uh and it's more than just a
parallel I think it's part of a fractal
consequence and that is this a
caterpillar is one of the most voracious
insects you've ever seen you put a
caterpillar on a plant like a monik
butterfly and they on a milkweed plant
and you put that caterpillar on that
milkweed plant it eat every damn Leaf
off of that plant I mean and I see it
right here in in my yard there's a plant
and the caterpillars the monarchs love
that they put their caterpillars on
there I come back a couple days later
it's not one single leaf left on the
plant they ate all of the leaves and I
go then what I said well guess what they
reached the end and what do they do they
form what is called a pupa or
Chrysalis and then I say well what's
that well it's a cocoon I said then
what's happening in there I say it's a
miracle what's happening there I said
what's the consequence of that's
happening I say a caterpillar came in
and a butterfly goes out I go wait
what's the difference I say the
caterpillar is the most voracious eating
everything and the Butterfly that comes
out is the lightest touch on the planet
floats in the air essentially doesn't
destroy anything and it lives and it and
it enjoys the beauty of it because it's
living in harmony I say why is it
relevant now let's go back to us I say
we're the caterpillar phase of human
civilization we're the eating everything
and we pushed it against the wall now
and nature says that's it I said now
what I said well we have to go through a
metamorphosis I say why we need a
civilization that comes out on the other
side that's in Harmony and Health and
Living in the garden with cooperation
that's what def our destination is I go
well wait how do you go from caterpillar
to butterfly I go ah in that Chrysalis
that cocoon what was going on a
caterpillar came in
and then what started to break down and
the cells started to come apart and the
community started to come apart and the
caterpillar starting to disappear and if
if you were a caterpillar cell you'd go
oh my God the caterpillar's dying and I
go what's happening it's disassembling
and I said then what's
happening certain cells called imaginal
cells become directors they say look
there's a new way to build here's a new
construction we're going to build this
butterfly so as C are coming down cells
are also now moving in to build the new
one okay so I said if you're in the
middle of this it looks like chaos it's
like oh my God the whole thing's falling
apart and I go yeah but guess what as
it's falling apart a new one is being
built we are in the Cocoon Puba stage at
this moment the caterpillar that we've
been is destructive anymore pushed it
can't do it what do we have to do we
have to transform I say how do you do
that take the structure of the
caterpillar you bring it down and you
build up the structure of the butterfly
and I say but they're happening at the
same time well that's the confusing part
because then you as a bystander in the
middle can look one way and go oh my God
it's fully apart and then you can look
the other way and go oh my god look what
they're building I say so where are we
well most people are oh my God it's
falling apart I go wrong place to put
your energy your vibration pull out of
that start to look like participate
because there's something being built
out here that's so much better positive
thinking can heal you of any disease
negative thinking can create any disease
it can even kill you you believe you're
going to die you're that's the belief
and I say so belief the picture is
translated into chemistry brain and the
chemistry via the blood goes to the
cells and controls genetics and behavior
so your thoughts are the primary control
control of your genes and I go
significance just simple conclusion the
old story what is called genetic
determinism genes determine the
character of your life that's what most
people learn is is no longer valid uh it
is now recognized uh that the genes are
receptive to the signal that you send
them and all of a sudden I say well then
your thoughts are overriding your genes
I go yes they do and then I conclusion
which Mark has been talking about for
years years is well then you better
start thinking healthy thoughts because
it's the negative thoughts that put the
chemistry in that that will create any
disease uh and all of a sudden it goes
positive thinking negative thinking but
it's all connected to belief one of the
most important principles of science is
that our Consciousness is creating our
life experiences and yet when you talk
to people and you say how's your life
going it's like well it's not really
going the way I would like it to go and
then comes the most important question I
say well what is it you really want want
you know what's interesting you can ask
people that question most people respond
saying well I don't want this and I
don't want that and I go no what is it
you want and I go they never really
focus on what they want they just see
what's not working and say they don't
want that and I go but what does this
lead to I said well if you're focusing
on what you don't want you know I don't
want this I said you know there's a
picture in your mind that corresponds to
what you just said your mind sees an
image I don't want X I don't want Y and
I go well that image you just said you
don't want is an image in the brain
whose function it is is to translate
that image into reality because
Consciousness is Crea reality which
means hey the placebo effect is a
reality based on positive Consciousness
and everybody goes yeah positive
thinking can heal me of any disease I go
yeah that's Conscious Creation what we
don't talk about is that negative
Consciousness manifests equally
powerfully as positive Consciousness but
it works in the opposite direction and
it's called nobo effect it's it's just
an expression that negative thought
manifest negative reality what is the
immune system well generally it's
something that protects me from what
from things that get inside your body
and I said well why should things want
to get inside my body in the first place
let's set up a
scenario you're out there in the world
and I drop you off in the wilderness and
I say okay survive and one of the things
you have to do is start finding food and
you're going to spend all your time
maybe find nothing and you're going to
be looking for food and here's an
alternative Vision I drop you out and
eat all you can Buffet well you don't
have to worry about food it's being
served to you all the time what does
this have to do with the immune system I
go like this bacteria parasites that
live out in the environment have to
struggle for their survival to find food
but underneath your skin the tissues
inside your body are flush with fluid
from the blood and in that fluid are all
the nutrients and elements necessary for
growth so if a bacteria could find
itself inside to your body it would be
sitting pretty all it have to do is just
sit there and food would be constantly
delivered from an individual circulatory
system so the idea is well yeah then
obviously this is a nice environment
that uh invasive organisms would like to
find themselves in because it's like
free food what you know no problems so
okay so what does this mean it says well
then we have to have a defense system
because if invasive organisms get in
there not only will they utilize the
food we make but they could create a
toxic waste environment that could
actually undermine our health so we
can't afford to have invasive organisms
come into us and take over and the
immune system's job is an internal
protection system as opposed to for
example the adrenal system fight or
flight which protects you from threats
on the outside immune system protects
you from from threats on the inside so I
said well how does it work well the
immune system is an intelligent system
because what is the function of the
immune system to go out into the world
of their body and look for things that
are new that came in and then not only
recognize them but learn about them so
that they could create antibodies for
example to effectively knock them out so
the immune system's character is
learning and memory I go wow what a
coincidence this is the character of the
nervous system point the immune system
is an extension of the nervous system
learning in memory about the environment
in which you live so I said well how
does it work well I say that there are
organisms that prefer to find the
interior of our body as a place to live
because it's so much easier for them
just to sit there and uh live off of
your energy and your nourishment so the
old story is oh the immune system uh
protects self my body against invading
organisms as everything else is called
not sself well I go that's a crude
Insight but it's not anywhere near
accurate for a simple reason the immune
system identifies things that get into
the body that cause disruption of the
system and its job is to identify them
mark them and eliminate them I go but
there you know there are many organisms
that live with us that are part of us
it's called the
microbiome thousands of species of
organisms bacteria and parasites living
with us I say the immune system doesn't
attack them the reason is this they
support our viability they support who
we are so self versus not self that's
not the discriminating factor of the
immune system factor of the immune
system is anything that's disruptive to
the system well guess what that not only
includes organisms that coming from the
outside but even our own cells if they
go Rogue like go into a cancer state the
immune system's job is to eliminate them
so basically the function of immune
system is to keep Harmony in the system
any organism that comes in that disrupts
Harmony function immune system
eliminated energy psychology is a new
version of psychology that engages
something called super learning super
learning what's that I go maybe seen
somebody read a book by moving their
finger down the page just as fast as
they move that finger down the page they
read everything on both you know on the
page on both Pages boom they could just
read it so the idea is this well what if
you can engage super learning and uh use
that in downloading a new Behavior you
ready you can change a belief you had
your whole life 50 60 years you can
change that in minutes because super
learning is the equivalent of pushing
the record button on on the subconscious
super learning allows you to download a
new program in minutes and we need that
why because the behavior that the
culture and civilization using today is
so out of harmony with nature that
humans are causing their own Extinction
at this moment it's called a mass
extinction NASA scientists have have
already told us that industrial
civilization the one we're in uh is
facing and I I want to emphasize this
because it was in the title of the
report and I just I said we are facing
an
irreversible collapse of civilization in
the next couple of decades well we're
seeing it right now civilization is not
working the chaos that's all over the
planet is a sign that it does not work
this way and if we don't change then
we're facing our own Extinction the
subconscious mind is one million times
more powerful and works 95% of the time
versus the small conscious mind working
5% I said that's the one that's stressed
that's the one that's struggling it says
I want something and I'm not getting it
and I'm going to make it and I go you're
trying to change the world when your own
behavior was the one that was sabotaging
it and that's because you didn't see
your programs and like Bill you engage
these programs and you don't even know
you have these programs but then as I
said well if you want to see your
programs your life 95% coming from the
program your life is a printout of your
programs the things you like as I said
they come in they came in because you
have a program to acknowledge them but
if you understand the things you
struggle over are not because the
outside is preventing you from getting
there it was your own invisible 95% of
the day playing programs you didn't even
know you had and that's where the
sabotage comes from and yet we want to
blame and fix everybody on the outside
and think that we're just the recipients
of all this without recognizing we're
the creator of all this and that sounds
like oh so new Agy and I go listen
quantum physics is the most valid
science on this planet and principle
number one quantum physics Consciousness
is creating our life experiences you
want to change your life you don't
change the world you change your own
Consciousness the world changes after
that whatever you're waiting for be a
peace of mind contentment Health it will
surely come but only when you're ready
to receive it with openness and
gratitude of all the characteristics
needed for both a happy and morally
decent life none surpasses gratitude
happiness and health are the just
rewards for living in
gratitude wow I remember the first time
I read that I doubted that gratitude
could give me health and happiness but
now I know
differently eigor eigor how sweet of you
to remember my birthday listen let me
blow out the candles make a wish and
then we'll have a party
later ah yes another year would be
wonderful well you know what that whole
story that Ben Franklin told us about
gratitude and health well it actually
works and now scientifically we know why
because built into every one of our
cells is the Fountain of Youth what's
the Fountain of Youth in the cell well
it's something called tiir tiir they are
special parts of the DNA so when you
open up the nucleus of the cell
the chromosomes come out and there are
46 chromosomes 23 from your mother and
23 from your father but what is a
chromosome well what it is is a sleeve
of protein wrapped around a double helix
of DNA and the significance about this
is the tiir as you can see in this
picture of an X and Y chromosome stained
red are the tiir at the ends of the
chromosome they're the ends of the DNA
are I say so what is the tiir it's
extensions of DNA after the genes
meaning it's a part of the DNA that
doesn't program anything it's just
extended DNA happiness and gratitude now
that's the big one happiness and
gratitude means you love your life so
much that you want more so unconsciously
you will activate the enzyme to increase
and enhance your life this is also
associated with a positive outlook
because if you have a positive outlook
that means you're looking toward a
future and again feedback says then
we're going to have to to activate this
enzyme to have that future and the last
two aspects that enhance the enzyme and
give you long life are very important
and that is again having that self-love
appreciating yourself which means I'm
enjoying and appreciating my life
experience and when you're in love that
of course drives you to stay around even
longer and that will activate the enzyme
and lastly and most importantly is being
in service meaning you have something to
do and what the feedback of the system
is says I can't and now I have to be
here longer I have something to do and
so being in service is one of the most
important things to extend your tiir and
keep you around and in conclusion the
information about tiir and tar Ras is
very important because they represent
the equivalent of a fountain of youth in
every cell and between your mind and
your cells the biology belief reveals
how your Consciousness and your thoughts
can extend your tiir by activating taras
when you appre apprciate life when you
have gratitude and when you're looking
for love and happiness on the planet you
can extend your life so interesting
you're very powerful to change your life
and make it one of happiness joy and
health for a long long time what do you
mean by being able to change inner
Evolution because we all really do
believe that genes are
Destiny well the biggest story comes
down to knowledge is power and everyone
goes yeah we all know knowledge is power
but let me put it in a better way for us
now is a lack of knowledge is a lack of
power and a misperception by definition
is a lack of knowledge and now I have to
say we have been for the last 50 years
operating under two very uh important
misperceptions a the one you brought up
genes control our life this is totally
false uh and the second one is actually
uh the idea of a Newtonian universe
that's split into physical matter and
invisible energy and two different
Realms and they don't communicate and
whatever is physical should be you know
interfered with by something that's
physical so that's why we have
pharmaceutical drugs we have a physical
body you want to fix it you have to give
it something physical so those are the
drugs and that's an outdated and
disempowering illusion because it turns
out it's energy and Consciousness that
shape the world and and and let me just
emphasize it so it's not so it's so
weird sounding it's Consciousness our
mind is creating this well quantum
physics is to me the most valid science
on the planet uh even before it was
fully understood the theoretical ideas
that were presented have all been
actually realize that uh that this is
such an amazing science quantum physics
and I say so relevant about this valid
science I go the first principle in
quantum physics is consciousness is
creating our life
experiences and uh you know that's oh
that's so new age I go no that's about
as hardcore science as there is and uh
this Consciousness uh and and this is
why I love working with you Lynn because
your job has been raising Consciousness
around the world and that is how we're
going to evolve is uh not physically
evolve but we're going to evolve with
Consciousness and so uh the knowledge uh
that you're providing for people is
empowering and I like to do the same
stress hormones shut off the immune
system okay so that's two problems right
away growth maintenance shut off by
blood vessel squeezing shut immune
system stress hormones directly inhibit
the immune system so I'm not putting
energy in to internal problem when I'm
being chased and then I I always call
the third one the insult to the injury
you just injured your body now you will
know what the insult is I told you the
stress hormones in the in the gut
squeeze shut when you're in fear that's
a butterflies in the stomach you can
feel it it say queasy queasy and I go
what else the stress hormone shut the
blood vessels off in the thinking brain
back right here the the prefrontal
cortex and when the blood is squeezed
the blood vessels are squeezed shut here
the blood is pushed to the hind brain
that's where reflexes occur and
reactions occur no thinking so guess
what under stress you shut down thinking
and now you're just reacting and I go so
you lost the power of your Consciousness
it's not working I need to empower the
people because they have been invisibly
disempowered without the knowledge that
their life is coming from programs that
they didn't even put in there right so
true and these programs rarely support
what you want so you play the programs
and all you find is you're not getting
what you want those programs never gave
it to you you know a famous book uh
kosaki wrote a book called Rich Dad Poor
Dad this is truth here is simple truth
if you grew up in a rich family you were
programmed how to be rich and how to
have money if you grow up in a poor
family you were programmed to recognize
you don't have any money and you don't
have any power and I say then a rich
person will stay Rich why because 95% of
their life is coming from the programs
they downloaded from the rich parents
who made all the money the poor person
is going to stay poor because 95% of
their program comes from the poverty
mentality that their family experienced
when they were young and all of a sudden
it says well then you got programmed you
want to be a rich kid or a poor kid I
said well what the hell was your program
right and the big one that we're talking
about David is the program of fear
because we've all been programmed with
some Vision other people have told us
about the afterlife the fear the hell
the Nation Oh I don't want to die I go
hey from what are called near-death
experiences where people have died for a
period of time almost every one of them
said the exact same thing it was better
out there than it was back here again
and you know because a lot of them when
having this experience they're giving a
choice do you want to stay here in the
afterlife or you want to go back and
most of them would prefer to have stayed
there but have obligation
and came back right but the point was
yeah you're not this physical body
you're the broadcast you're the energy
but when you're playing through this
body then you're the experiences of your
life at this point when you're out of
body you are the energy and the energy
is forever people don't realize the
power programming I'll give you one
right now cancer is one of the leading
causes of death in in in the world right
now and I go but what I go there's no
Gene that causes cancer
what oh well they're enco jees we call
these cancer genes like the breast
cancer Gene I go those are genes
associated with cancer they don't cause
the cancer for you know example so many
women live in fear of the breast cancer
Gene CU so many have it but they live
what's the fear I'm going to get the
cancer I have the Gene and I said that
fear is a vision which is manifesting
into their reality but then I go you
know 50% of the women that carry the
gene never get the cancer I said what's
the point the point is this possession
of the gene didn't cause cancer it was a
lifestyle that was undermining your
biology that activated expression of
these genes the gene didn't activate
itself so all of a sudden it says oh my
goodness then the idea of cancer didn't
come from the genes I go no it came from
the programming programming of
disharmony dysfunction not living in
life the fears that are programmed
because our Consciousness is creating
this world oh that's quantum physics oh
yeah that's up in genetics oh yeah
that's absolutely right that's Placebo I
go what do you mean I'm sick and the
doctor says this the greatest newest
research pill ever it's going to cure
you you take the pill you get better and
you go oh yeah that was great and then
you find out the pill was a sugar pill
there's a very important point then what
the hell heals you right the conscious
belief that you would be healed
manifested healing and every oh yeah
Placebo my thoughts manifested my
reality go that's exactly what it's all
about and yet while we are in a
discussion of placebo what people don't
discuss which is much more important to
understand is well positive thinking can
heal us negative thinking is equally
powerful in controlling the character of
our lives so that negative thinking can
cause any disease even death if you just
believe you're going to die you can die
just from the belief of it wow looking
at the world and seeing what's going on
right now all the chaos the upheaval
that's going on is so distressing at one
level and it's interesting for me
because as a scientist I can stand up
and talk about the fact that today's
chaos is a necessary requirement for the
evolution that we would love to see and
yet I like you have to live in this
crazy world it's mindblowing it's crazy
and it becomes really important because
all of this stuff that we're hearing is
motivating fear and fear by its
definition is disempowering because when
you're in fear you're expressing I have
no power to take care of myself and we
give up power and we give it up to other
people to create the world for us and
obviously by looking at this computer
and watching what's going on around the
world those so-called leaders are not
really helping us get to the destination
of a heaven on-ear reality and it's time
to recognize yes fear takes away our
power I've talked about that in many
many lectures talked about the fact that
stress hormones actually shut down our
Consciousness and puts us into a
reactive mode well this is not a time
for reaction this is a time for creation
and this is what the emphasis of quantum
physics has been telling us that it's
our Consciousness that is making
creation and yet if we're living in fear
and Consciousness is coming from Fear
then what world are we creating well
that the chaos we observe every day on
the news so in this situation what we
really have to do is just listen to the
words of Franklin D Roosevelt when he
said the only thing we have to fear is
fear
itself also relevant today are the
profound words by Frank Herbert in Dune
where he says fear is the mind killer
and this is what we have to recognize
well I've been talking about the fact
that Consciousness is created our world
and I say it's based on science well let
me give a very important fact it was in
1927 in the founding of the science of
quantum physics that we get the most
important Insight from one of the
founding fathers of quantum physics Max
Plank and what does Max say all matter
originates and exists only by virtue of
a force we must assume behind that Force
the existence of a conscious and
intelligent mind he
concludes this
mind is the Matrix of all matter well
that was what 70 more years ago 100
years ago I say has that changed I go no
look at this for example this is an
article out of the most prestigious
scientific journal on this planet nature
and I say what's this article I said
it's called the mental Universe it's by
a Quantum physicist at Johns Hopkins
University I'm not going to go and
describe everything he says in the
article because Richard KH Henry the
author summed it up in the last sentence
let me emphasize for you that last
sentence in this article on quantum
physics the universe is
immaterial it's mental and
spiritual live and enjoy an interesting
thing about the Matrix is that we're
given a choice to take either a red pill
or a blue pill taking the red pill wakes
us up and the blue pill puts us back to
sleep those that have taken the red pill
believe they really have awaken but the
fact is this biologically speaking how
do you know whether you're really awake
or whether you're still asleep the whole
point about this is when you're asleep
and you're in a dream you don't know
whether you're awake or in a dream they
all seem exactly the same some people
like to consider the Matrix is nothing
more than a science fiction film but in
truth it's actually a documentary we've
all been programmed and 95% of our life
is coming from the program we are not
living the life that we desire because
we have have been programmed but what is
the real nature of taking the pills in
the first place as we've described
before we came here to make a choice do
we take the red pill or do we take the
blue pill as the Oracle says how can I
make a choice if you didn't come here to
make the choice you've already made it
you're here to try to understand why you
made it whether you take the red pill or
you take the blue pill that's no choice
at all because that choice is taking the
pill either one but it's a taking
situation and the problem with this is
civilization has been taking for
thousands of years taking and taking
from where from Mother Earth nature
taking her resources and using them to
the extent that there are no more
resources from Mother Earth we're facing
a problem now as being takers we as
being takers have created what is called
the six mass extinction of Life on this
planet we have taken so much from nature
that nature is collapsing the real
choice is is what is the opposite of
taking and that is giving and this is
what nature is calling upon us to do
right now stop taking from nature and
let's give Back To Nature because this
is the only way we can create balance
and Harmony in our world nature is the
source and it is time for us right now
to return to that Source through this
chaos nature is teaching us how to learn
to live in harmony with each other as
well as learn learning to live in
harmony with nature itself this is the
point of cooperation to come here and
create and maintain that balance of
Harmony and peace humankind has been
programmed with the delusion that we are
separate from each other and we are
separate from Mother Nature herself the
real choice we're being asked to make is
whether we want to live in polarity or
whether we want to live in harmony the
difference being in polarity we have
opposite sides in conflict in cont
contrast in harmony the opposite sides
work together and complement one another
and this is completely different that
the polarity everything's going right
but the whole beautiful part about it is
well if it doesn't go right okay stop
now let's go do something else because
it's the idea it didn't go right and
then why didn't go right and who didn't
make it right and where is it going to
go now and blah blah blah and what are
you doing you're digging a hole and it's
not going up it's going down and the the
whole idea is choice but the most
important part of choice is you have to
stop long enough not get caught up in in
the in the program and play out the
program there's a moment while you're
playing the program maybe you can
separate and look at yourself and say
why am I doing this because that is the
moment of power that is the moment where
you can say I have a choice I can do
something totally different than to Stew
in this stuff and then you are a
powerful person do you see value in
going backwards in other words in
Psychotherapy or in going back to the
past no and but why wouldn't I why
didn't I see value in it and I said
because when you go back and Replay that
problem you've exercise that problem
again you have pushed the buttons that
created the problem in the first place
that's why they have so many boxes of
tissues in the in the psych office
because you're going to cry your eyes
out why because you're going to be
replaying the trauma of what caused the
problem and this is the cool part it no
longer exists it's not there anymore
except for you carrying it with you and
there's a point where I say well then
why should I go back and repeat this
because it's just going to cause a
replay of the same program which
reinforces that program I go I don't
care about the past I care about here I
am today I want to go this way what do I
want today I don't care about what
happened back there not that I should
forget about it because I don't want to
replay it again but it doesn't control
me anymore because I say replaying that
is just the you know putting that in the
old days they had records you guys don't
know about but they had need record and
if you keep the needle gets deeper in
the in the group I go we don't want to
play it again so it's irrelevant to go
back I like it there's a story of two
Buddhist monks monks are not the the
male monks are not allowed to touch
women and these two monks are walking
along the path and they come to a river
and there's a woman all dressed up in
her wedding finery and she's crying and
crying and it's what's wrong and she
says well I can't get across the water
and you know I'll ruin my clothes and so
one monk just picks her up walks across
drops her on the other side and then the
two monks walked down the street about
half hour 45 minutes later the one that
didn't pick her up turns to him he said
you picked up a woman back
there and then the other monk says I put
her down 45 minutes ago you're still
carrying
her you get the story the story is this
it was over the history is over do I
want to repeat it no so there's a way of
seeing what it was but I don't have to
repeat it because I have to say what is
it I want not what is it I don't want a
lot of people I don't want this I go
yeah but what is it you want people have
more problems answering what it is they
want than saying what they don't want
and the important part about this is you
can only move into the future that you
want by acknowledging what you want not
saying I don't want that anymore I said
well that didn't that didn't give you
your future uh and and so yes there are
ways to reprogram the subconscious uh
and when you do your life will change in
permanently as you understand the term
quantum physics and quantum mechanics or
Newtonian physics and Newtonian
mechanics what you see is that physics
and mechanics are synonyms so physics
really means the mechanisms by which the
universe operates and the new physics
quantum physics was something that I
really wasn't into nor were any of my
colleagues in the medical school we were
all trained in Newtonian physics and the
difference between the two is very
profound Newtonian physics says the
world that we live in the universe we
live in is a is a machine made out of
mechanical parts if you want to
understand how it works take it apart
study the pieces change the pieces
change the operation That's the basis of
medicine we look at a human body it's a
machine made out of physical parts when
it's not working right change the parts
by buying chemicals and drugs and that's
the way that conventional medicine
operates when I started to read the
quantum physics I realized oh my
goodness the the whole foundation of the
universe is not based on a mechanical
physical Universe it's based on the
invisible energy called the field so
let's say if I hold a magnet right here
in front of you you can see the magnet
but what you can't see is the invisible
magnetic field and and so what it says
is well we are physical things in our
world like physical bodies we're
immersed in fields electro magnetic
fields magnetic fields itself all kinds
of fields like telephone uh cell phone
Fields uh television Fields radio Fields
whole
ranges what is the difference between
the newtonium physics and quantum
physics is this newtonium physics focus
on the particles quantum physics says
you want to understand why the particles
take this shape then you have to
understand the field it's the field that
controls biology it's the invisible
forces there's a great quote by Albert
Einstein and it's it's simple it goes
the field is the sole governing agency
of the particle in other words in the
world of invisible things fields and
particles matter it's the field that
gives shape to the matter and this is
the basis of quantum physics this
becomes relevant it says okay here's the
physical particles of my body why are
they in a healthy state or why could
they be in a sick State that's the
physical expression and the answer is
well to understand that don't look at
the body you have to understand the
invisible forces in the field uh is and
it's fun because if you think about when
when when of course when you were young
at some point you must have had like
iron filings and sprinkled it around a
magnet and all of a sudden you saw the
iron filings form that pattern of the
magnetic field well quantum physics
would look at this pattern and try to
explain how come all the iron filings
fell in this pattern without recognizing
that the field exists in other words can
you explain why the iron filings have
this shape if you don't recognize a
magnetic field the answer is absolutely
not what's the nature of it the body and
its cells are like iron filings medicine
is trying to understand the nature of
the body by looking at the iron filings
and quantum physics says if you don't
understand that invisible field you
can't understand what's happening in the
body the body provides us with
Sensations pain love joy happiness anger
whatever it comes from this mechanism
it's a mechanism the the eyes take in
light but they don't they don't see
light back here in the brain they see
energy vibrations sound comes in my ears
I don't hear the sound I hear the
vibrations taste that's a vibration it's
a chemical vibration all of a sudden oh
my God this is a
transducer it takes life experiences in
a body that gives us vision and smell
and taste and touch and pain and love
and joy and and I say and this is sent
back to our source so we came here to
have life experiences and I go at that
moment of Awakening I said oh crap
here's a major difference between men
and
women men are not allowed to have these
sensory experiences and I'll give you a
reason but women are so women are
sensitive and that's a way of life for
them they're sensitive and then they go
about but men are so insensitive I go
that was a program we were programmed to
be insensitive for a very simple reason
you cannot be a soldier if you're
sensitive you can't kill somebody if
you're sensitive so men have been
knowingly
programmed to lose
sensitivity so they can be used to do
those jobs like killing somebody else
and I go oh my God then I missed the
reason for being on this planet I missed
the feeling of what is love all about
you know what are these senses of joy
and happiness I'm not allowed to
experience him as a guy because uh that
interferes with a soldier job I go I'm
wasting my life and that was a wake up
call I said well damn it go out and
taste it and touch it and feel it and
smell it and do whatever you want and if
it's really good do it again and if it
didn't work out so good then don't do
that one again you came here to have
these experiences why would you want to
waste your life having all the negative
fear anxiety all those problems it was a
choice it was
Consciousness but we didn't know that
because we were programmed to be victim
and a victim has no power and as long as
you believe you're victim then you
manifest
victim and this is why I'm so uh honored
to be with you Jeff because you're
experiencing this you know this stuff
you're trying to get this message out to
the other people why to wake us all up
because we came here to manifest heaven
on Earth like falling in love and I go
then what about all this war and
pestilence and plague and and all these
things I go oh that's a
manifestation and we're manifesting it
you can live in this world without even
being involved with all those things you
just have to change who you are and what
you are and what you want conscious mind
versus programs subconscious mind and
when you understand this you become
empowered and I say empowered to do what
I say create heaven on Earth and then
people think oh you die and go to heaven
I go boy is that a big mistake because
you're going to get to the Pearly Gates
St p Peter's going to be there and he
says well how was your experience in
heaven he said what do you mean I said
you were on earth right that's Heaven
why that's where you came to create
what' you create I
go I don't want to wait till the end
man my my my mother remarried when she
was relatively older and she married
this guy who was I said kogy guy was not
really happy guy or anything he lived to
be like 995 96 or something he had
cancer my mother took care of him at
home the last week of his life he
essentially wasn't there he was just
comos more or less in the bed and then
two days before he died he all of a
sudden his eyes opened up he was there
and he looked at my mother and he said I
didn't have any
fun and all of a sudden I just said holy
crap he's going to die in two days and
he woke up today he didn't have any fun
I said that's not me babe because when I
finish it's going to be that was great
let's do it again
how effective is your conscious mind at
overwriting the subconscious I say it
works 5% of the time with a miniature
computer and I go well that's your
problem I go the only way you can
override the program is not play the
program and that's when we said stay
Mindful and then we then said well
that's going to be difficult because we
have to think so there's only one way
out no no don't keep it a secret tell
everybody there's only one way
out re program the subconscious mind and
I go significance if you would put
wishes and desire programs into the
subconscious mind that means that that
program would be operating 95% of the
day
meaning whether your conscious mind is
in control saying these are my wishes
and desires or the conscious mind's
thinking then the subconscious mind
comes in and said these are my wishes
and desires then guess what then 100% of
your life you're living wishes and
desires
and therefore all of a sudden then the
the the work has to come back to each of
us as individuals each of us got
programmed each of us is manifesting
that program we give up our power in
many of the programs fine example is you
were sick as a kid and just like your
parents and any other family members
when you were sick you went to the
doctor I go that's a habit I said what
does it mean it says you learned this in
the first seven years a program he says
when you're sick you give up this power
and you go to that doctor and you accept
the doctor as the power of over you
because when it came to health it's like
no no you don't do it the doctor doesn't
that's the program I say so what's the
point you have given up power over the
control of your life and have given it
to the truths quote unquote offered by
the doctor I go significance I go the
doctor misreads your
diagnosis and then tells you oh I'm
sorry you only have three months left to
live and I go significance 95% of the
day the program says the doctor is the
you know the correct one the TR what do
I know the doctor knows what do I know
so 95% of the day then your belief
system is going to do what take the
words of the doctor and manifest them as
truth I go what's that mean well you're
going to die in about three months I go
from what I go hey that was a
misdiagnosis you're still going to die
because your belief system will man EST
an illness that will terminate cancer
for example is not due to any genes
there's no Gene that causes cancer the
genes are correlated with cancer and I
go what causes cancer I say disharmony
and repressed anger is one of the big
ones I go so then I say the genes didn't
cause I say no so I said then what
caused it I say my Consciousness I say
what repress anger you know I go so what
I say well change Consciousness and
guess what you can go into remission
the cancer will go away as soon as you
change the Consciousness and all of a
sudden it's like I thought I was a
victim of the genes I said that's a
program and that is totally
incorrect because as quantum physics
says Consciousness is creating our life
experiences and as the new biology which
I'm familiar with called
epigenetics is how Consciousness
controls the
genetics and all of a sudden I say oh
well then biology and quantum physics
now share the same story yeah you're
creating this and the idea is that if
you look at the creation you're not
happy with it don't go out and blame the
creation because you never saw that you
were participating in a way invisible to
you that led to this
expression if you want to change it you
have to change you and then the
environment will change the
fear which is human
specific is the fear of mortality
there's no other organism that knows
it's going to die and I say that
fear is what then we gave up our power
to have somebody assuage that fear it's
like oh it's not so bad or whatever you
know we we bought what religion why did
we buy religion well I'm going to tell
you about what happens after you die the
big mystery and I say oh then all of a
sudden guess what they made the program
for my life I go who the hell are you
that make a program for my life well I
bought it because was in fear and fear
means I have no power and when I have no
power I'm going to seek someone who says
they have the power and then I'm going
to accommodate what they do and so
people join into religion because they
have the fear of the afterlife well I'm
going to tell you the beautiful part
about my research was I didn't believe
in spirituality okay I had no to me
afterlife was oh I'm chemicals and when
I die I go back into chemistry you know
that's what it is but when I understood
this I said oh my God I'm an immortal
entity I'm a spiritual field quantum
mechanics a field and all of a sudden I
started to realize oh my
goodness I have no fear why I'm not
going to die I'm not even in here so how
the hell am I going to die and once that
fear was gone my life was radically
different I tell you why because we all
live with that biological imperative
that says I'm afraid to die and I said
'w what if you're not afraid to die what
if you don't see death as an end what if
you see as just a transition into
another way and all of a sudden I say'
what the consequence of that is no fear
I said then what does that mean I say
then I'm more powerful because it was
the fear that took away my power and if
I don't have fear then you can't scare
me and I don't I'm not scared and I
don't care about your rules about
afterlife because I have my own
understanding now you don't have to try
and tell me about afterlife I know what
I am I'm a spirit I'm an energy field
the immune system protects you from a
threat on the inside yeah but if the
tiger is chasing you who cares about the
threat on the inside I I got a bacterial
infection and a saber-tooth tiger
chasing me where where should I put my
energy and the hell with the infection a
tiger catches you that infection is not
a problem anymore so very important fact
profoundly everyone listen stress
hormones specifically shut down the
immune system because the taking care of
the inside is not as important as taking
care of the whole thing running away uh
in fact stress hormones are so good at
this that when doctors want to
transplant an organ from person a into
person B the recipient of that organ is
given stress hormones before the
operation because it reduces the
function of the immune system which
would be rejecting The graft and so you
don't want the immune system to reject a
graph so you give them stress hormones
which what shuts down the immune syst
system I go well guess what in today's
world just watch the news for a moment
and all of a sudden your immune system
is
going yeah so that's number two so
number one stress hormones shut down
growth because feeding the viscera for
its functions not worthy of running away
I need to get the blood into the arms
and legs uh again to conserve energy
because look the immune system use a lot
of energy if you ever been sick
sometimes you don't have the energy to
get out of bed so it's like well when
it's operating it could drain you of
energy yeah but if you're being chased
by a saber-tooth
tiger the hell with the immune system uh
and so you shut that down so those are
two insults to the system in other words
if I'm not under stress I I'm nourishing
my body and I'm encouraging my immune
system I'm staying healthy but the
moment I'm under stress both of those
things shut down and I'm ready to to
fight or flight uh and then I I said
well there's a third one I call that
adding insult or injury and the answer
about what that means is this the brain
has the forebrain where conscious
thinking is conscious thinking and the
hindbrain which is like habit and reflex
Behavior conscious thinking is slow I
mean imagine your car is going out of
control and it's spinning and I say stay
in the conscious mind it's like
oh I say yeah but the moment the car
starts to go out of control the stress
hormones go in remember I told you they
squeeze the blood vessels in the gut
they squeeze the blood vessels in the
forebrain I say why because it pushes
the blood to the hindbrain which is a
million times more powerful than the
forebrain as a machine processor and I
go so why is it relevant I go because
the moment the car is going out of
control is oh turning the wheel hitting
the pedals you're doing everything
Beyond fast so fast okay yes so when
you're in a stressful situation thinking
is
slow and therefore the system doesn't
want want you to be slow it needs you to
go boom react reflect right away so the
blood vessels from the same chemistry
squeezing the blood vessels down the gut
squeeze the blood vessels here push it
to the hindbrain we become less
intelligent when we're under stress
because now we're reactive and it gets
to a point that sometimes you're so
afraid that you take care of me and then
we give up we give up control to the guy
with the bigger stick yeah you take care
of me well that means we're a victim
victim means we're powerless I go when
stress hormones are in the system the
only Power you have is to run and I go
and relevance about that is very is very
simple and that is that it was only
designed with saber-tooth tigers in mind
I go why is that R I say well the
saber-tooth tiger is chasing you I go
yeah and I'm running like crazy I got
blood in my arms and legs I got all the
energy I say yeah but if you escape that
tiger in a few minutes of running then
there's no more threat and then all of a
sudden the stress hormones are gone and
then you're back into growth and
everything else but today stress is
247365 a human body was never designed
to be maintaining a stress situation
because it suppresses the Vitality of
the system and in today's world with the
idea of Co everyone's
afraid I go and guess what the one thing
you wanted was your immune system to
work and the one thing that's not
working because you're afraid is the
immune system I go the more fear people
have the sicker they become yes and this
is a wakeup call that says man we have
to stop listening to that fear drum they
keep beating the drum every oh
everybody's gonna die I don't know
somebody going to die you know there are
people who are indeed vulnerable because
they're already stressed immune system
people that live in stress are already
open to a problem uh older people whose
immune system is are not working up to
the fullest capability they're under
threat because their immune system is
already compromised and then there's the
people with what are called
comorbidities go what are they I say
these are stressors on the system that
are chronic overweight is one of the
biggest ones uh in the serious cases of
covid
78% of those serious patients were
overweight why overweight is a challenge
to the system and you're already
challenging your immune system before
the damn virus showed up so that's a big
problem uh diabetes type two meaning
that's a stress World diabetes is a
stressor that's in the system the more
stressors that you have going the less
effective your immune system is so it
turns out here's a number number
unfortunately
Americans is
60% of Americans have at least one
comorbidity they're slightly compromised
okay but 40% and this is where the issue
comes from have two or more simultaneous
comorbidities these are people that are
ripe for infection why their immune
systems are already compromised before
the damn virus showed up so it's like
well then I'm am I afraid of I said well
if you're a healthy person no if you're
you know if you're a compromised person
then you should be taking care of
yourself I don't have to take care of
myself you have to take care of yourself
because you're the one that's open and
yet we want everybody to put on the mask
and everybody to get the vaccines I go
that the that's stuff I was gonna say a
bad word that
stuff is not valid I go what you mean
it's not valid I say
the country of Gibralter
100% of that population has been
vaccinated and guess what Delta went
through there like a plague man and I
said yeah but they were all vaccinated I
go yeah because the vaccine doesn't work
I go well yeah but now Omron I go no the
vaccine doesn't work and they say well
get your booster shot I said get the
booster shot it didn't even work the
damn first time why should it take the
second time it does not work and so the
real issue is this
we have to take care of our health uh
and not wait for other people to protect
me from them if I'm a vulnerable person
it's my responsibility to take care of
my health what are the main limiting
beliefs that you just hear consistently
that most people tend to have if they're
not in a have a higher level program
that they've caught and switched with
well one of the main beliefs that
they're caught up in is the uh lack of
power they feel over their own health
and their own reality that I'm a victim
I'm a victim of my genes I'm a victim of
this world out here I say if you if a
the belief system uh is translated into
Behavior if I believe I'm a victim then
my behavior will be as a victim no power
you guys tell me what to do and I'll try
and do what you just said and I say well
that's the biggest problem of all
because quantum physics I mentioned is a
most valid science and principle number
one is you're the creator of this it's
like well when are you going to own that
and the answer is I could say it but
then you walk away and a few minutes
later you're back into your world again
everything's gone you know listen took
me a while uh I learned and understood
that oh my God this is how it works and
I was so excited I wanted to get people
I wanted to tell anybody listen to sence
this is how it works so I I beginning
got some people together and I started
to go off let me tell you how to create
the most beautiful life experience and
then they'd look at me and they go you
know lip in for a guy who says you know
this your life doesn't look that good
interesting it was my wakeup call that
said how the can I talk about how
wonderful this is and I'm not practicing
it and I immediately said to myself no
don't go out there and talk to anybody
about this why until you do it so what
were the what were the things that were
holding you back
before you've discovered this and then
what was the new program that you
started to implement for yourself on a
consistent basis to have a 100% upgraded
program yeah well um one of the things
professionally okay I was doing a great
job I I had a great professorship in a
medical school all that kind of stuff
you know personally my life sucked
really get a relationship off the ground
I go why not I go well now that I know
about it I was was programmed about
relationships by observing my father and
my mother well they had dysfunctional
relationships so what do you think I
downloaded dysfunction so my conscious
mind goes forward and says yeah I want
to have a great relationship I get into
it my subconscious mind steps up and
says so this is how we're do a
relationship you oh uh oh game over you
know why because I didn't see the
negative behaviors that I was putting
out my partner potential partner saw
them and gave them cause for alarm I
don't think I want to be with this guy
you know that was me and then I realized
that and that's when I really had to go
in first thing and start to change who
am I and I'll tell you the biggest
problem now after years of working
people do not love
themselves and I said what does that
mean I said if you have a program where
you don't love yourself then rationally
logically can anybody else love you the
answer is no because you don't think
you're lovable that's right and somebody
says you are that oh I love you and then
you go well you know you probably don't
have any quality control I know I'm not
lovable what's wrong with you you know
and then at some point you push them
away and then they're not there then you
go I'm not lovable nobody's here I I
push them away you know and I changed
that I was nearly what 45 years old 40
some years old and I had zero quality
relationships for all that life right I
changed the program and within a couple
of years I I'm now with my partner
Margaret and and the fact is she was
involved with a um workshop training
program for people so she understood
processing and stuff and when I came and
we added the science and the processing
uh we've been living a honeymoon for 26
years really years waking up every day
going wow still here another day for fun
another day for being in love it was
great and it still is but if I didn't
change the program that would never have
been part of my life at all I would have
been my whole life struggling it's been
a very strange year on this planet chaos
is happening all over the place and
we're looking at this going on what's
going on with our world it seems like
it's turning upside down the answer is
it is turning upside down now that might
be the bad news for most people but it's
actually for my insight it represents
the good news you go how could it be the
good news that the world is so filled
with chaos and the answer is simply this
is that human behavior has precipitated
the six mass extinction of Life on this
planet which includes us five times in
the history life was thriving on this
planet in some event like a comet
hitting the Earth upended the entire
ecosystem wiping out up to 90% of life
this is a six mass extinction and the
source of this is much closer to home
than a comet because the source of our
Extinction is human behavior we are
undermining the web of life and as a
result there's a collapse of nature
going on all around us if we don't
change we're going to go extinct I'm not
talking A Thousand Years folks I'm
talking decades from now so what you're
seeing is a collapse of a foundation
civilization is changing so rapidly Co
has pushed it super fast all of things
are changing with the co the way we work
in the world and we commute on the world
things like that are profoundly
different now and we're moving into a
different way of life we are not going
back to the old way of life we are
creating a new version so when you look
at the world falling apart Don't Be
Afraid actually be very joyous why if it
doesn't fall apart Extinction is right
here in a few decades if it falls apart
it gives us an opportunity to create
something better to move from here to
there mind controls not just what genes
are being activated but M can alter the
blueprint I can make 3,000 different
proteins from the same blueprint just
based on how I see the world so all of a
sudden it says wow we are very powerful
We're The Architects and we can create
Health but we can also create disease
because we're the creator of it okay so
now comes the the the big part and that
is this to me the most valid science on
this planet is quantum physics quantum
physics I say that because uh back in
1927 when it was theoretical they came
up with a whole bunch of things you know
Albert Einstein Max plank Heisenberg
they came up with a theory of how
everything worked well it's nearly a
hundred years and guess what almost all
of their theories are totally accurate
so we have a deep deep understanding of
quantum physics Consciousness is
creating our life experience principle
number one it was back in 1927 Max plank
founder one of the founders said the
mind is the Matrix of all matter that's
where the movie The Matrix comes
from when you think about someone who's
an artist and they're creating a
musician a chef chef chef or or in love
like you're in the flow right so you're
because you're you're not thinking yeah
you're not thinking you're doing and it
doesn't mean there's not participation
it just means that you're not thinking
of the future you're kind of just time
and space sort of change like you lose
track of time that kind of stuff yeah
not thinking means not diverting to the
subconscious meaning you stay in
conscious creativity yeah conscious
creativity is wishes and desires so a
chef uh is so involved with the cooking
and paying attention to all the details
they're not thinking and I say well what
does that mean they're not coming from
program they're coming from creativity
okay the artist the chef uh the race car
driver yeah not thinking man uh you know
we're in it we're g I had a m tell me I
should write a book called the speed of
Consciousness well that that's it and
the subconscious is much faster than the
conscious and that's why in times of
Emergency the conscious is too slow to
help us and that's why we jump to it but
then the problem is whatever Behavior
you're going to express while you're in
that subconscious was a program that you
had a positive or A negative well up to
60% of the programs that you downloaded
are not positive they're disempowered
programs in the year 2018 astronaut Dr
Bruce Lipton set out on a voyage to save
Humanity upon the assumption that Earth
was dying and humankind needed a new
home however just prior to launch new
studies emerged from Chernobyl the once
devastated landscape has regrown Nature
has returned unfortunately something
went terribly wrong and Dr Bruce Lipton
was sent into outer space many problems
occurred and Dr Bruce Lipton became lost
lost in the vastness of
space this is his journey after 20 long
years being Lost in Space Bruce Lipton
is finally coming home oh wow what a
welcoming sight look at that beautiful
blue green gem floating in the darkness
of space I'm going home it's going to be
great now if I could just get this ready
for re-entry Michigan trol Michigan
troll astronaut Bruce lton coming back
home from the outer limits with our
beautiful rocket ship please come
[Music]
in I guess well maybe they're they're
just busy right now but well I've got
such a great story to tell them when I
get
[Music]
back
oh fresh air man being in that little
can for 20 years out there this oh it's
so wonderful oh it's beautiful it is
beautiful here God just think of it how
much time I spent out there in open
space looking for another place for us
to live another planet and I come back
here and look at this it is so beautiful
I didn't ever have to leave gosh when I
left here this whole place seemed to be
falling down man the environment was
collapsing all around us the rain forest
were being cut down people were
destroying the air the water the land
look at it now wow these people have
really created something new ah created
something new well that's not an
accident a creation is a
participation at that time when I left
and the world looked like it was on its
last stages something happened they
people must have learned how to change
the world but in order to do that they
first really had to learn how to change
themselves you really have to understand
at some level if we're going to create a
garden like this and somewhere along the
line we had to create the own garden in
our own Consciousness first and that's
where we start to come from reality
humans have imagination they can imagine
a garden but then humans have the
ability to manifest recognize this you
have 50 trillion citizen cells living
under your skin a community that lives
in harmony if we really want to
understand how to live in harmony well
look Within
that's where the answers are how can 50
trillion cells provide for a happy
healthy human being because they
understood the nature of community it's
a fractal universe and fractal Universe
simply means this a structure geometry
of the universe that represents As Above
So Below meaning if you understand the
structure at any level you can
understand it at any other level and so
if we really want to understand how to
create this beautiful planet then we
have to recognize it this how did the
cells do it in our body because 50
trillion of them came together in a
community and learned to live in harmony
and provide for their environment but
then if we understand how the cells did
it then we can understand how the people
can do it because we have to use the
same principles it's fractal to change
that planet and make it the garden that
it has become right now but then of
course you can't get there if you don't
know where you're going so before we
even embark on the trail we must first
visualize and our consciousness
what is it we're seeking what are we
trying to manifest where are we going
and once we get that picture in our mind
then we can become the artist to
manifest that picture in the real world
situation and just by the looks of this
Garden we obviously must have learned
our lesson and of course where are these
people where are these
people hello hello
hello
you Maniacs you finally did it you blew
it up damn you all the
hell and in today's world we're told
don't go by the feelings if I did I
would have probably been better off at
this moment so when we recognize we have
to make a decision we can do it in two
fundamental ways first do an assessment
an analysis of step by step what does
this decision mean and why should I
choose it but when you get to the end
before you absolutely take that
information and make a decision based on
that ask your heart and the reason why
is this the heart doesn't care about the
individual steps in the decision the
heart only looks at the conclusion
either you get more energy from this
decision a good vibe a Feeling that this
is right or the heart will give you a
feeling of bad vibes less energy a
feeling that maybe this isn't the right
answer so the significance is really
profound because the heart just reads
energy and higher energy is more life
less energy is less life so in making a
decision yes it's acceptable to do the
analysis but before you come to that
final decision please check in with your
heart
feel the feelings if the feelings are
good that means go toward that direction
but if you feel questioned about it you
feel weaker about it doesn't just feel
right the heart is telling you right off
that that energy is not good for you and
you should use some other decision oh
wow that's so wonderful what a wonderful
way to make a decision based on these
feelings and they can help us find the
direction that we need to go in and lead
us to a better
life
uh-oh I guess that's not really working
for me at this moment whoops oh well
computer and
[Music]
simulation Scotty how many times have I
told you not to leave me off and se you
know I can't swim me me at the bridge
you have some explaining to do well the
other day I was going through my toy box
and guess what I found something I had
seen for a long long time my wonderful
wonderful ETA sketch now many of you may
have had this when you were young as
well but I really loved it you know why
it gave you an opportunity to make a
drawing on this screen by turning these
dials down here and then after you
complete the drawing you can then Shake
It Up and the drawing will disappear and
you can make another drawing so it was
like a reusable pen and paper just shake
it and make a new one so here let's take
a look at how you do it and I'll try it
it's been a long time since I've done it
but uh let me work at it here's how it
works so well you can see I'm a little
out of practice on it but here's the
beautiful part here's a drawing that I
just made and I created this image and
then manifested it on the screen of the
etra sketch so what's really interesting
is what I can do is now shake up this
screen and erase the image and then I
can create another one perhaps this one
is going to be a little better than the
last one let's see what I can do this
time well what a great picture but what
we can do is just shake it
up what the hell is going on behind me
oh my God the world is
collapsing so why is this relevant
because there's a lot we can learn about
Evolution through an etos sketch wow
what we're experiencing right now is a
process called Evolution well it's not
the evolution we learned in school the
Darwin version that's the kind of
evolution that says Evolution has
gradual changes over billions of years
imperceptible but over a long time you
see an outcome that's different in
contrast to the old version of evolution
the gradualism version there's a new
understanding Evolution called
punctuated equilibrium uh this is a
theory that was devised by Steph J ghoul
and Niles Eldridge and what did they
recognize is that when looking for
fossils there were different layers
where fossils of animals that no longer
exist and then there's like a space and
then there's another layer with fossils
of animals that no longer exist and then
another space and they said well there's
something going on there's a development
a punctuation another development and a
punctuation the punctuations are natural
events that destroyed the nature and the
Web of Life at that time and in fact the
last one of these mass extinctions is
attributed to a giant Comet that hit
near the Yucatan Peninsula and upended
the web of life and at that last
Extinction 66 million years ago remember
before the comet hit the planet was
filled with lush tropical forest and
dinosaurs after the comet hit they don't
exist anymore the strata that we see in
the fossils is really the same story as
we see in the AES scatch the strata
means that something happened there was
a picture then the picture changed and a
new picture formed on the next strata
and then that picture changed the
understanding about the nature of the
etes sketch and what's actually going on
in our world right now are really the
same story we've created an image it's
not sustainable and and the edes sketch
is shaking but the planet is shaking the
planet is telling us that Civilization
you have created is no longer
sustainable and it's time for us to
create a more thrivable sit situation
for us to move into the future there's
an old saying there's no such thing as a
new story well in fact interesting point
we can go back thousand years to start
to recognize that the Buddhists were
telling us the same story in a different
fashion they were making what are called
sand mandalas and these are very orate
Creations from different Sands instead
of paint different sand creating a
structure and then making this most
beautiful structure and they also
recognize just like the universe is
things don't always stay the same so
after they create this most beautiful
expression then they take all the sand
and scoop it all together make a big
pile and start all over again for
another image just as in the story with
a mandalo and the same story in the edes
sketch and the same story that we're
experiencing on this planet right now
there's a very important point that says
that we can move into the future but
take with us what we learned from the
past to build a better future to thrive
into that future and this is where we
are right now shaking it up so that
civilization come together in a new
version with love Harmony and peace
while we're in this state of chaos it's
a very important point about you the
Observer of what I've just been talking
about I go why is this important because
you represent cultural creatives you are
the people that are looking for answers
to how to get into the future from the
destruction we're facing right now and
the answers are not in the box so just
by even watching what we're talking
about right here is the idea to give you
the Insight of how powerful you are in
creating the new future your
participation is involved in this
Evolution this is not a passive event
you sit at home and wait for evolution
this is where we go out and manifest
Evolution and just like in the story the
etes sketch you can put your hands on
the dial and start to create a new image
as well and so collectively when we all
work together the new image is a new
civilization one that can take us from
today into a future this is the moment
of manifesting a new civilization
not just for the people but for mother
nature herself and this is our
opportunity to participate in conscious
evolution if we understand what's going
on we can flow with nature instead of
resisting it yes and flow out of the
chaos which is not random but taking us
to the new world right and therefore uh
if we can learn how to change our
behavior and become more in harmony with
the world which is what nature is
calling on us to do then we can create a
sustainable thrivable situation right
now uh it's not sustainable uh the
system is crashing because we cannot
maintain the way we have lived so that
means we have to change the way we live
and I go yeah but that's culture and
that's behavior and so it says you have
to change Behavior then we have to let
go of a behavior to create a better
behavior and well most people have to
hit their heads against the wall and go
through all this process again what
we've been talking about is well can I
make it easier and the answer is of
course you can make it easier uh we can
do psych balance and change behaviors in
minutes and so we don't have to be part
of the struggle in the chaos we could
already be at the new end wait for the
other people to come out of the chaos
and join us because you made it this far
in a video I want to celebrate you most
people start and don't finish most
people never actually follow through
most people say they want something but
they don't ever do the work to actually
get it but you are different you are
special believe Nation you made it here
all the way to the end and I love you so
as a special celebration if you put a
hash believe down in the comments Below
on this video I will showcase you and
celebrate you somewhere on the screen in
a future video because you are awesome
for some incredible Michael Singer
motivation check the video right there
next to me I think you'll love it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there mindfulness is about this it is
about finally waking up one day and
saying I'm the boss I'm in here I have a
mind I can do better with it than
letting it scare me all the time then
letting it remind me of everything never
bothered me